IT AFTERNOON WILL START TODAY'S
HEARING THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET. SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE AND TODAY IS
THE MAY REVISE HEARING. GOING
OVER THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
BUDGET PROPOSALS. DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET BUT- DAYS
INFORMATIONAL ONLY- WE WON'T BE
HAVE VOTING ANY ITEMS TODAY-
WE'LL HAVE PUBLIC COME AT THE
END OF COURSE A SO HERE WE ARE
IN- IN YEAR TWO A REALLY YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR WE SAID IT ONCE
IN A GENERATION BUDGET AND I
GUESS THIS IS PART TWO OF THAT-
THAT- HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO
INVEST IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND YOU KNOW REMARKABLE. WHERE
WE'D BEEN A LAST TEN YEARS AS
FAR AS PER PUPIL FUNDING
ESSENTIALLY- DOUBLING IN THIS IN
THIS IN THIS- LAST DECADE OR SO-
SO BIG PICTURE SO WE CERTAINLY-
OUR AGREEMENT THE SAME- REVENUE
NUMBERS FOR PROPAGANDHI EIGHT
GROWTH- I THINK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE THAT WE
HAVE IS A BIT OF A DIFFERENCE IS
IN. ONGOING VERSES ONE TIME AND
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO IN A BIT HE IS- WE'D LIKE
TO SEE- MORE MONEY GOING ON
GOING TO THE BASE AND- YOU KNOW
WE WENT AWAY FROM THIS.
CATEGORICAL BASED PROGRAM A
DECADE AGO TO THIS EQUITY BASED
FUNDING FORMULA FOR A REASON AND
WITH THESE ONE TIME MONIES I
THINK WE SEE A LITTLE BIT TOO
MUCH. AS FAR AS THESE ONE TIME
CATEGORICAL AS THEY SOUND GOOD.
BUT WE WE'RE SEEING DISTRICTS
AREN'T ABLE AREN'T ALWAYS ABLE
TO SPEND THE MONEY BECAUSE THERE
ONE TIME AND THEIR PEOPLE JEVON.
IDEAS AND SO- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE GOING TO WANT TO
ADDRESS ADDRESS AND HAVING MORE.
ONGOING MONEY TO THE BASE- FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO FOCUS ON
THEIR- PRIORITIES- OF COURSE WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO. BE MINDFUL AND DEAL WITH-
THIS PANDEMIC AT COVIDIEN YOU
KNOW TOO MANY KIDS. ARE FACING-
LEARNING LOSS AND- AND KIND OF
GET BACK IN THE SWING OF THINGS
AS FAR AS RECOVERY- AND THE LAST
THING THAT I DO WANT TO TOUCH
ON. IS THIS WHOLE ISSUE WITH
SCHOOLS HAVING. DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND ATTENDANCE
VERSES- ENROLLMENTS. AND I'LL
JUST SAY IT STRAIGHT UP I THINK
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
GETTING SUPER DISTRACTED. YOU'RE
FOCUSING ON A FEW COINS ON THE
GROUND AND NOT LOOKING IN FRONT
OF YOU ON THE POLLS. WHERE THERE
IS HUNDRED DOLLAR BILLS
PLASTERED ACROSS YOUR FACE.
BECAUSE WHAT THIS MEANS IN
SIMPLE ENGLISH HIS WE HAVE FEWER
KIDS. GOING TO SCHOOL BUT
BECAUSE OUR PROP NINETY EIGHT
WE'RE GETTING MORE MONEY TO OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS SO. IT'S LIKE
SOMEBODY WHO HAS A JOB WE'RE
GONNA GIVE YOU MORE MONEY FOR
DOING LESS WORK SO GRANTED WE
HAVE TO RECONCILE THAT WITH THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT BASE BUT THE
MONEY'S NOT GOING ELSEWHERE IT'S
NOT GOING TO. CORRECTIONS BUDGET
IS NOT GOING TO THE RESERVE IS
GOING 240% TO OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SO LET'S NOT GET.
SIDETRACKED ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE NATIONAL TREND WITH
THE- DECLINING ENROLLMENT WITH-
DEMOGRAPHICS AND SO FORTH- WE
ALSO HAVE THE ISSUE THAT WE ARE
REALLY. MINDFUL ABOUT AS- CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION- WE
KNOW THAT LAST YEAR WE SET ASIDE
A PROGRAMMING TO TAP THE FIRST
TIME. A UNIVERSAL EARLY AT THREE
FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS VIET
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
KNOW THAT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE IS
CHILD CARE. WHICH WE WHICH WE
SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN IS STILL
UNDER FUNDED AS FAR AS THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WE NEED TO.
MAKE SURE WE GET REAL AND FINISH
THE JOB AS FAR AS RATE-
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR OUR CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- SO WITH THAT- WE
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO
GO OVER THERE PROP NINETY EIGHT.
PROPOSALS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HERE ABOUT THAT- BUDGET
LETTERS AS WELL AND THEN WE'LL
GET TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ENGAGEMENT AND THEN FINALLY
PUBLIC COMMENTS. BEFORE WE GO
MISTER O'DONNELL OPENING REMARKS
YES I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY- TO
HEAR PRESENTATIONS TODAY- WERE
AN INTERESTING MOMENT. BUT I
KEEP HEARING PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
MORE MONEY MORE MONEY YES MORE
MONEY BUT I WAS ALSO WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT COSTS ARE HIGHER.
AND SO IT'S AN HISTORIC NUMBERS
WAS INFLATION TO STORE RIGHT NOW
TO. WE DON'T CELEBRATE AFTER
THAT IS A FACT SO I CAN HERE'S
MY LITTLE CHARTS SOME OF YOU
HAVE SEEN MY CHARTER. THIS IS
THE- TO THE O. S. C. P. I RECALL
IN MY OFFICE THIS IS THE
O'DONNELL SCHOOL COST PRICE
INDEX AND IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
CHART IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE WHAT YOU'LL SEE-
IS. CPI CONSUMER PRICE INDEX IN
MARCH WAS EIGHT POINT 5% OSCARS
IN PERSIAN MIX THOSE GET ABOUT
TWO POINT THREE FIVE PERCENT.
THEY'RE DIFFERENT RATE INCREASES
FOR EACH. SYSTEM STORAGE CENTERS
BUT TWO POINT THREE FIVE FOR
THAT AND THEN YOU IF YOU LOOK AT
OTHER SCHOOL OTHER COST
PRESSURES RETURNING UNIQUE TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WERE ABOUT
FOUR POINT 15% THAT WOULD DIFFER
ACROSS THE STATE OF COURSE THAT
NUMBER AND THAT COULD BE A
VARIETY OF THINGS- COULD BE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT COULD BE
TRYING TO HIRE PEOPLE TO GET IN
THE DOOR- THE NEED TO INCREASE-
YOUR WAGES. THIS ESPECIALLY IN
THE CLASS RIGHT SIDE IS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO GET CLASSIFIED
FOLKS IN THE DOOR RIGHT NOW BUT
THE SAME TIME TEACHERS TO EITHER
LOCAL. ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
HUMAN RESOURCE TO SHARE WITH ME
THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HER
CAREER SHE SAW PEOPLE JUST
LEAVING TAT. THE PROFESSION
COMPLETELY. WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU SIGN UP FOR THE YEAR THAT
THEY GONNA KEEP YOU THERE FOR
THE YEAR BECAUSE IF YOU LEAVE.
THEY'LL THEY CAN SEIZE YOUR
CREDENTIALING GO AFTER YOUR
TEACHING CREDENTIAL A DISTRICT
CAN. THAT THAT'S REALLY THE HOOK
TO KEEP YOU THERE FOR THE FOR
THE YEAR. BUT WHAT THIS
SUPERINTENDENT ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT SHARING WITH ME
WAS THAT FOLKS WERE STILL
LEADING THEIR SINGLE NEVER USE
MY CREDENTIALS AND I'M I'M
LEAVING I. CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE
SO- WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE IN THE
DOOR- SO THERE'S COST PRESSURES
THERE SOARED ABOUT FIFTEEN
PERCENT. WHEN YOU TAKE THE CPI
ETCETERA CPI- PENSION OBLIGATION
AND THEN OTHER COST PRESSURES
ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT. ABOUT 15%
ON THIS CHART AND YOU LOOK AT
THE GOVERNOR DID JUST WHAT LAST
WEEK IT'S ABOUT 10% AND I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR DOING
THAT. SO NOW WE'RE HEADING INTO
CONVERSATIONS WHERE I WANNA PUSH
THAT BASE ALLOCATION UP. HEY I'M
AIMING 415% PLUS. BECAUSE OUR
SCHOOLS NEEDED AND WE. CAN DO IT
THE MONEY IS THERE. OUR I
APPRECIATE WERE THE GOVERNOR.
UNDER AND AS AS BEEN MANY. AND
OTHER FOR. I AM A BIT CONCERNED
THAT WE SEEM TO BE SENDING SOME
OF THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY. OUTSIDE
OF THE CLASSROOM OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL DAY- I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S COMPLETELY LEGALLY
DEFENSIBLE QUITE FRANKLY- GIVEN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IN THE
MANDATE. AS TO HOW WE SPEND THIS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS. BUT AGAIN WHAT A VERY
IMPORTANT MOMENT AND I
APPRECIATE OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
TODAY- INTERVENE IN RECOGNIZING
THAT WE NEED. TO BUMP UP THAT
BASE YES WE NEED TO DO THAT. WE
SHOULD ALSO HAVE ANOTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT SCHOOL
FACILITIES. SCHOOL FACILITIES
ACTUALLY IMPACT. THE COST OF
HOUSING. IN SOME AREAS CROSSES
OUR STATE BECAUSE OF THERE IS NO
MORE. MONEY IN THE STATE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM TO KEEP IT
SIMPLE THERE'S NO MORE MONEY
THERE. THAT RUNS OUT. WHAT
HAPPENS IS LEVEL THREE FROM
LEVEL FIVE THREE. A DEVELOPER
FEES KICK IN. THAT MEANS OF A
DEVELOPER BUILDS A NEW HOUSE IN
A HOUSING PROJECT THEY'RE NOT TO
FIND A SCHOOL. ON TOP OF THAT
THAT MEANS THE PURCHASER. OF
THAT NEW HOME. IS GOING TO PAY
FOR THAT NEW SCHOOLS WELL WE'VE
HAD A PARTNERSHIP FOR YEARS-
WHEN THERE'S MONEY IT WORKS
WELL. AS A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP- TO BUILD SCHOOLS-
AND- MODERNIZATION TO MODERNIZE
SCHOOLS- SO AGAIN I HOPE THAT WE
HAVE- INCLUDE OUR CONVERSATION
THE NEED. TO INCREASE THE MONEY
FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES IN THAT
WOULD BE OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT. AND AGAIN I KNOW
ALL AGREE HERE THAT THE SMARTEST
THING WE CAN DO WHETHER MONEY IS
TO. PAY A LONG TERM DEBT. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHERS OTHER
IDEAS TO THE WILL BUT WE TALK
ABOUT AS A LEGISLATURE. BUT VERY
SIMPLY THAT THAT THAT'S WHERE I
STAND INCREASING THAT PACE. A
SUPPORTING SCHOOL FACILITIES I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATIONS. TODAY MISTER
CHAIR. OKAY YOU ANY OTHER HOPING
COMMENTS BEFORE WE START. I
SEEING NINE LET'S BRING UP.
LET'S BRING UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND R. ELIA- TO GO OVER
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT MAY REVISE
OVERVIEW.
HE'S BEEN. HI WELCOME PLEASE
PROCEED HI- HELLO CHAIR NUMBERS
I'M I'M AND SAYING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL BE
PRESENTING YOU WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THEIR PROP NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE AS WELL
AS THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA FOR THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE MAYOR VISION YOU
BRING TO MAKE LITTLE CLOSER. IS
THIS BETTER WAY BETTER THANK
YOU. YEAH THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IS ESTIMATED TO
INCREASE BY ABOUT NINETEEN POINT
SIX BILLION ACROSS THE BUDGET
WINDOW FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THIRTY FIVE POINT SEVEN
BILLION RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT.
GROWTH IN THE GUARANTEE IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO GROWTH AND
GENERAL FUND REVENUES. ALL
BUDGET YEARS REMAIN AND A TEST
ONE WHICH MEANS THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY 38%
OF THE REVENUE CHANGES IN EACH
OF THE THREE YEARS AND THE
BUDGET WINDOW. THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE IS RE BENCH TO
REFLECT THE CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
NUMBER ONE TIME VERSUS ONGOING
PROP NINETY EIGHT POLICY
ADJUSTMENTS AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. OF THE SIXTEEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
EIGHTEEN POINT SEVEN IS ON GOING
AND SEVEN POINT NINE BILLION IS
FOR ONE TIME EXPENDITURES.
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE OR ADA
IS PROJECTED TO DECLINE ABOUT 5%
FROM FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THERE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. EIGHTY EIGHT
CALCULATIONS INCLUDE UPDATED
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT MILLION ROLLING T. K.
STUDENTS AS WELL AS FEWER
STUDENTS ABSENCES. EXPECTED
TUDOREL COVERED NINETEEN. IN
REGARD TO THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RAINY DAY FUND THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTED THAT A TOTAL OF NINE
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN PAYMENTS
TO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT WOULD BE
NEEDED BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWO. TWENTY THREE.
ADJUSTMENTS IN CAPITAL GAINS
REVENUES AT THE CURRENT MAYOR
EFFICIENT HAVE REVISED THESE
REQUIRED PAYMENTS DOWN FROM THAT
NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION NOT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO A CURRENT
NINE POINT FIVE BILLION. ON NOW
MOVE ON TO LCF. OKAY ACTUALLY
THE ON THE GO NEXT CAN. HI SURE
I CAN COUPON WITH THE LEAD
GENERALIST OFFICE THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE INCREASE IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE AT THE NINETEEN POINT
SIX BILLION OVER THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD IS REALLY A BIG STORY BUT
IT'S NOT A VERY COMPLICATED ONE-
COMPARED WITH JANUARY REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE UP ABOUT FIFTY SIX
BILLION OVER THAT PERIOD SO THE
INCREASE IN THE GUARANTEE IS A-
JUST UNDER 40% OF THAT AMOUNT-
WE THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
GENERAL FUND ESTIMATES. REVENUE
ESTIMATES ARE REASONABLE THEY'RE
FAIRLY CLOSE TO- THE ESTIMATES
THAT WERE FINALIZING. A SMALL
PORTION OF THAT INCREASE IS
OFFSET BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S.
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE- THIS
BROUGHT DOWN THEIR ESTIMATES
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE BILLION-
COMPARED TO JANUARY. AND WE
THINK THEY'RE A LITTLE LOW ON
THAT ONE- WE THINK PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE IS LIKELY TO COME IN. I
CLOSER TO JANUARY AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT HAPPENS THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE I WOULD INCREASE ON A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS- THAT'S
KIND OF OUR I TAKE ON THE
GUARANTEE ITSELF- I CAN TURN
THINGS MAYBE BACK TO MICHAEL TO
GET FINANCE IF THEY WANT TO GO
OVER SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
SPENDING FROM. THE BIG TICKET
SPENDING ITEMS. SURE. NINETY
OKAY- INSING DEPART OF FINANCE-
ALL OF ALSO NOW- FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AT MAYOR VISION
THE LCF DECREASED BY ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
COMPARED TO BUDGET OCT ARE
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT
WHICH POINT WE HAD PROJECTED AN
INCREASE OF TWO POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
PRIMARILY DUE TO HIGHER
PROJECTED A DIETA KLEIN OF ABOUT
5% BUT A LARGE COLA INCREASE OF.
SIX POINT 56% WE ALSO PROVIDE A
TWO POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
DISCRETIONARY ONGOING INCREASE
TO THE BASE L. C. WHICH COVER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AS ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF
RISING PENSION OBLIGATIONS
INCREASE COSTS FOR GOODS AND
SERVICES. AND OTHER LOCAL BUDGET
CONCERNS. THIS INCREASE WILL
FLOW THROUGH THE LCF FORMULA AND
WILL INCREASE NOT ONLY THE BASE
GRANT BUT THE CORRESPONDING
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS AS WELL. LANGUAGE FOR
THIS ONGOING ADJUSTMENT WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE FORTHCOMING ARE
AN- IN REGARD TO DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PROTECTION FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE DECLINING
INTRO ENROLLMENT PROTECTION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR OF APPROXIMATELY
TWO POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
WHICH REFLECTS A REVISION OF THE
THREE YEAR DECLINING ENROLLMENT
PROTECTION FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BY MODIFYING THE COMPUTATION. OF
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSES OF THREE
YEAR AVERAGE. THIS PROTECTION IS
PROVIDED FOR DISTRICTS AS AN
ONGOING ADJUSTMENT FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE PROVIDE A ONE TIME
DECLINING ENROLLMENT PROTECTION
FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR FOR CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ONLY. IN THE
AMOUNT OF FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. TO
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WE PROVIDE
AN ONGOING BASE INCREASE TO
THEIR L. C. F. AS WELL. THIS
WILL BE IN THE AMOUNT OF ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS. THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS
REGARDING LCF OFF. THANK YOU.
HELLO AND IF I CAN I'LL JUST
DIED FINISH UP REPRESENTATION
HERE I THINK THE TIMING OF
FINANCE GIVE YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW
OF THE BIG STRUCTURE OF THIS
PACKAGE IS ABOUT THIRTY THREE
BILLION AND TOTAL PROPOSALS
INCLUDING SEVENTEEN BILLION
THAT'S NEW IN IN MAY AND- AND
THEY WERE AT AND ON TOP OF MONEY
THAT WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- JUST IN TERMS OF THE
STRUCTURE THE BIGGEST ONE TIME
ALLOCATION IS EIGHT BILLION FOR
THE DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANT
I'LL THINK WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT. A LITTLE BIT LATER- FOR
THE ON GOING ON MEDICATIONS- THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
RECEIVES MOST OF THE ON GOING
INCREASE- THAT'S PROBABLY THE
MOST COMPLICATED ASPECT OF THIS
PACKAGE JUST BECAUSE THERE ARE A
COUPLE DIFFERENT MOVING PIECES
BUT I THINK THE WAY TO STAY
ORIENTED IS TO FOCUS ON THE TOP
LINE NUMBER IS ALSO UNDER THE
MAY REVISION AT THE TOTAL
FUNDING FOR L. C. F. F. WOULD
INCREASE ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION- FROM THE
AMOUNT PROVIDED THIS YEAR GOING
INTO TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND THAT'S A INCREASE OF AROUND
TWO POINT NINE BILLION OVER
JANUARY AND THAT'S THE RESULT OF
THOSE- FOR ADJUSTMENTS YOU HEARD
LOWER BASELINE ATTENDANCE A NEW
PROPOSAL TO OFFSET THAT DECLINE
INCREASING THE STATUTORY COLA
FROM FIVE POINT 33% TO SIX POINT
56% AND THEN ADDITIONAL BASE
AUGMENTATION ON TOP OF THAT
WHICH IS ABOUT THREE POINT 2% SO
PUTTING THOSE THINGS TOGETHER
THE OVERALL INCREASE THE POLICY
A TEFT NEARLY 11% FROM THIS
YEAR. THE COMING YEAR- THE MAYOR
OF ASIAN ALSO CAN. AN
AUGMENTATION FOR THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION- SO IN
ADDITION TO THE COLA THERE IS AN
INCREASE TO THE OPERATIONS
GRANT. THAT WOULD AFFECT
DIFFERENT COUNTIES DIFFERENTLY
BUT WE THINK IT WOULD. ROUGHLY
AVERAGE A 15% INCREASE IN THEIR
LCF FUNDING. SOME COUNTIES
RECEIVE THOSE INCREASES EVEN
THOUGH THEIR FUNDING IS ALREADY
ABOVE THE LCF TARGETS. I JUST
TURNING TO SOME OF OUR COMMENTS-
SO THIS AS THE CHAIRMAN CHEN IS
THE LARGEST PROPOSITION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT KICKOFF
PACKAGE SINCE THE ADOPTION OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT-
SIGNIFICANT NEW AUGMENTATIONS-
BUT THERE'S ALSO SOME FEATURES
THAT WOULD HELP. US BUILD THE
STATE'S BUDGET RESILIENCY AT
LEAST WITHIN THE K. TWELVE
BUDGET. AND WE THINK THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT GIVEN SOME OF THE
ECONOMIC WARNING SIGNS ARE THAT
I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD
ABOUT FROM A FEW OF MY
COLLEAGUES YESTERDAY- SO THE
BUDGET. ALLOCATES NEARLY FOUR
AND A HALF BILLION IN ONGOING K.
CALL FUNDS TO ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES. THERE'S NOTHING
PARTICULARLY SPECIAL ABOUT. THAT
NUMBER YOU COULD GO HIGHER A
LITTLE HIGHER A LITTLE BIT
LOWER. BUT HAVING A QUESTION
LIKE THAT GIVES YOU THE ABILITY
TO DEAL WITH SOME KIND OF
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN A LOT MORE
EASILY- THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SERVE ALSO GOES TO NINE
POINT FIVE BILLION NEARLY 9% OF
THE GUARANTEE IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THAT'S NOT HUGE IN
THAT CONTEXT BUT IT'S A VERY
HELPFUL STARTING POINT FOR
MANAGING POTENTIAL VOLATILITY
NEXT YEAR IN THE YEARS TO COME.
ON THE LCF WE THINK THE
AUGMENTATIONS PROPOSED GENERALLY
ARE REASONABLE. I PROVIDING
INCREASE BEYOND THE STATUTORY
COLO WOULD ALLOW DISTRICTS TO
SUSTAIN PROGRAM EXPANSIONS. IN
THE FACE OF SOME OF THE COST
PRESSURES THAT ON. THE CHAIR AND
SOMETHING UMBRELLA O'DONNELL
MENTIONED AT THE AT THE OPENING-
WE ALSO THINK THAT THE PROPOSED
ATTENDANCE- PROVISIONS ARE
REASONABLE. BECAUSE THEY WOULD
MITIGATE THE TEMPORARY DROP IN
ATTENDANCE THAT DISTRICTS ARE
EXPERIENCING NOW WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING A LINK BETWEEN THE
FUNDING AND STUDENTS OVER THE
LONG TERM. THAT WE DO HAVE SOME
NOTABLE CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION FOR COUNTY
OFFICES- THE MAY REVISION WOULD
INCREASE FUNDING AT A MUCH
FASTER PACE THAN FOR DISTRICTS.
WE DON'T SEE A COMPELLING
RATIONALE FOR THAT AND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT WOULD MAGNIFY
SOME OF THE HISTORICAL FUNDING
INEQUITIES THE STATUS TRIED TO.
EVEN OUT OVER THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS WE RECOMMEND YOU REJECT
THAT PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD
PROVIDE AN INCREASE THAT'S MORE
IN LINE. WITH WHAT'S PROPOSED
FOR DISTRICTS- ON THE
DISCRETIONARY GRANT PROPOSAL- WE
THINK THAT'S AN IDEA THAT HAS
SOME MERIT- COULD HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ADDRESS THEIR HIGHEST
ONE TIME PRIORITIES- PERHAPS
COMPLEMENT SOME OF THE OTHER
ITEMS. ARE BEING PROPOSED-
DEPENDING ON YOUR PRIORITIES YOU
COULD THINK ABOUT PERHAPS
TAILORING THE INTENT LANGUAGE-
PERHAPS ADJUSTING THE AMOUNT
BASED ON YOUR OVERALL K. TWELVE
PRIORITIES. YOU CAN EVEN ADJUST
THAT PAYMENTSCHEDULE FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'D LIKE THAT TO
COMPLEMENT SOME OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS. YOU COULD CONSIDER
DISPERSING THAT- ON THE SAME
SCHEDULE- AS THOSE ITEMS- THERE
ARE A FEW SPECIFIC PROPOSALS WE
HAVE CONCERNS- WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THOSE IN THE NEXT PANEL BUT
SPECIFICALLY. ON SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION FOR THE
TEACHER TRAINING IN THE ARTS
MUSIC SET ASIDE. WITHIN THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM I THINK SOME OF THOSE
MIGHT BE PREMATURE GIVEN SOME OF
THE FUNDING THAT'S ALREADY. BEEN
PROPOSED IN JANUARY OR PROVIDED
IN PREVIOUS BUDGETS- ONE OF THE
LAST COMMENTS IS THAT WE'D
SUGGEST YOU GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO
POTENTIALLY PROVIDING. A LITTLE
BIT MORE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING FOR FACILITIES-
THE STATE RIGHT NOW HAS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT'S AVAILABLE SPECIFICALLY ON
A ONE TIME BASIS. AND USING
THOSE FUNDS FOR FACILITIES COULD
PROVIDE BENEFITS FOR SCHOOLS AND
PROGRAMS THAT COULD LAST FOR
MANY YEARS. WE THINK YOU'VE GOT
A FEW PROMISING OPTIONS-
POTENTIALLY HELPING DISTRICTS
OBTAIN FACILITIES FOR
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT'S A KEY
CHALLENGE FOR DISTRICTS AS THEY
GEAR UP FOR THE EXPANSION. OF
POTENTIALLY PROVIDING MORE
FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PROPOSED ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION IS A GOOD DOWN
PAYMENT. BUT WE THINK THE
BACKLOG IS LIKE THE EVEN LARGER
THAN THAT. OR EVEN PROVIDING
SOME KIND OF ONE TIME
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT FOR THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM. I
GIVEN THE DEMAND FOR ON GOING-
FOR MAJOR CONSTRUCTION
RENOVATION. I THAT ADDITIONAL
FACILITY FUNDING COULD QUALIFY
AS EXCLUDABLE CAPITAL OUTLAY
UNDER THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT. AND THAT WOULD EASE SOME
OF THE PRESSURE ON THE OVERALL
STATE BUDGET. AND LASTLY WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THAT DOESN'T
CERTAINLY DOESN'T NEED TO
COMPETE WITH ANY OF YOUR ON
GOING PRIORITY IS- THAT COULD BE
DONE ENTIRELY THROUGH SOME OF
WERE REPURPOSED AND SOME OF THE
ONE TIME FUNDS. ALLOWING
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS- FOR
LCS AFTER OTHER AREAS THAT MIGHT
BE LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES- SO
WITH THAT GOTTEN MY COMMENTS-
ACROSS ME I OTHER ITEMS AND
SUBSEQUENT PANEL HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. BOB OKAY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SORRY MR FONG. I THINK THIS
CHAIR- I WANTED TO- GO BACK GO
FOCUS ON THE FACILITIES
DISCUSSION I AM IN AGREEMENT
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH THAT WE DO NEED TO
INCREASE- WHEN THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING TO DEAL WITH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND- AND FACILITIES.
YOU INDICATED THAT- AND THIS IS
THE L. A- INDICATED. YOU DON'T
HAVE THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS ON THE
BACK LOG IS ARE THEIR NUMBERS
OUT THERE IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
SIZE OF THE- OF THE BACKLOG
WOULD BE. STATE DOESN'T COLLECT
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
CURRENTLY AT SOMETHING YOU COULD
START COLLECTING MAYBE AS A
CONDITION OF DISTRICTS RECEIVING
THIS FUNDING- BUT WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE STATE OF WROTE. ABOUT
TEN YEAR PERIOD REDUCED THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING DISTRICTS
REQUIRED THIS SPEND ON
MAINTAINING THEIR FACILITY IS- I
THINK OF IT AT THAT TENURE AS A
COUPLE AT LEAST A COUPLE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND SO BECAUSE AT THE
STATE ONLY RECENTLY RESTORED
THAT FACILITY SPENDING
REQUIREMENT WE THINK THERE IS A
FAIRLY SIZEABLE- BACKLOG. MAYBE
THAT QUESTION IS MAYBE I OF-
MAKE THAT SAME QUESTIONS APART
FINANCE DO DO YOU HAVE- ANALYSIS
OR A LIST OF WHAT THAT TO.
BACKLOG IS OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF SCHOOL FACILITIES
. WE DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC-
SORRY FOR THAT- CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC LIST OF
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
I THINK AS IT RELATES TO THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM THERE
CERTAINLY LIST OF THE PROJECTS-
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO OUT
OR HAVE HAD. APPLICATION
SUBMITTED THAT ARE ABOVE THE
BONDING AUTHORITY THAT'S
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE. DO YOU HAVE
A RESPONSE TO THE L. A. AS-
SUGGESTION OR RECOMMENDATION OF
INCREASING THE AMOUNT THAT GOES
TO FACILITIES AND FOR MINUTES.
CHOKE FOR THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM WE THINK- YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- PUTS FOR
THREE POINT NINE BILLION A TO
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM WE THINK THAT THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE STATE. TO SUSTAIN
THAT PROGRAM ENDED ITS CURRENT
PACE AND YOU KNOW AND-
ACCOUNTING FOR- CONSTRUCTION
COST INDEX YOU KNOW TAKE
CHANGES- THROUGH THE END OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ON A CALENDAR
YEAR- IN TERMS OF- YOU KNOW
BALANCING INVESTMENTS YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY- THE- THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
TWO. YOU KNOW ASSISTANCE TRICKS
IN IDENTIFYING- YOUR ADDRESSING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT. I AS THE ANALYST
POINTED OUT- ROUTINE RESTRICTED
MAINTENANCE COUNCIL REQUIREMENTS
HAVE RECENTLY BECOME ACTIVE
AGAIN- AND THAT REPRESENTS
ROUGHLY TWO POINT ONE TO TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL SPENDING- ON NOT
MAINTENANCE EACH YEAR. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC YOU KNOW
THOUGHT AS TO YOU SHOULD WE
INCREASE- YOU KNOW THE SPENDING
ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE YOU KNOW
WE THINK THE PACKAGE THAT WE PUT
FORWARD IS A- YOU KNOW
REASONABLE PACKAGE IN THE
TOTALITY OF ALL OF THE
PRIORITIES AND CALLS ON
AVAILABLE FUNDING- I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK THE- I THINK THE L.
A. O. IN AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PALM BEACH DO. DOES MAKE A
COMPELLING CASE AND I THINK THAT
WITH IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT. IT DOES
PROVIDE AN ADDED BENEFIT- AS
WELL SO JUST TO BE CLEAR. WITHIN
THE MAY REVISION. IT'S A TOTAL
OF THREE POINT NINE BILLION.
SPECIFICALLY FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS THAT CORRECT. BUT
IT'S UP THREE POINT NINE BILLION
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM WHICH
IS MODERNIZATION AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. THERE'S
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. IN PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT THAT IS SET SET ASIDE WORK
ARE INVESTED IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SAY IT WOULD BE
THREE POINT NINE PLUS ONE POINT
EIGHT. BUDGET SO IT'S SO THE ONE
POINT IT IS IN ADDITION TO THE
THREE POINT NINE BUT IN TERMS.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WAS WHAT COMES
OUT OF THE ONE TIME FUNDS IS
THAT IS THAT ONLY THE ONE POINT
EIGHT. UNDER PROPOSITION EIGHT
YES ONLY THE ONE TWENTY OKAY- IF
I COULD QUICKLY GO TO YOU- BUT
IT LET ME JUST ALSO ASK THIS
BECAUSE IKNOW THAT THE CHAIR IS
VERY FOCUSED ON ON TWENTY K.
EXPANSION WITH. THE THOSE WITH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FACILITIES-
MONIES WOULD THEY GO TO THOSE
FACILITIES AS WELL. THAT WOULD
BE GENERALLY A LOCAL DECISION AS
TO HOW TO YOU KNOW DEPLOYED THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROCEEDS
WITHIN THE SCHOOL FACILITIES
PROGRAM HOWEVER. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE ADDITIONAL AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE GENERATES
ADDITIONAL ELIGIBILITY WITHIN
THAT PROGRAM CERTAINLY THOSE
DISTRICTS COULD APPLY TO
PARTICIPATE THROUGH THAT
PROGRAM. OKAY AND IN MY- MY LAST
QUESTION MAYBE THIS IS THE COULD
BE VALUED BY FINANCE- IT CAN
SOMEONE SHED SOME LIGHT ABOUT
THE INVEST. IN THE AT THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM SUPPORT. AND IS
IT POSSIBLE IS THERE A NEED OR
WHY WE ARGUE THERE'S A NEED TO
INCREASE INVESTMENT BUT WHAT IS
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- THE NFL AS
ANY. ANALYSIS ON THAT. WE'RE
GONNA GO OVER THAT AND THAT MORE
IN THE NEXT SIX SECTION OKAY
YOUR GESTURE HOLD OFF ON THAT
QUESTION HERE. HOLD OFF ON THE
NEXT DOWNTURN. IN AND INVEST.
YEAH GO AHEAD RESTAURANTS- I
MAKE IT MY QUESTION IS-
BASICALLY OF TWO- IT'S WHAT IT
IS FOR MY FIRST WAS FOR THE L.
A. O- IS A LOT OF- A LOT OF GOOD
THIS BUDGET I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED- BUT I DO I DO HAVE
A QUESTION WHEN I WHEN I. WHEN
YOU ADD UP THE MONEY YEAH THAT
ONGOING VERSES ONE TIME- HOW
MUCH. IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET. HOW MUCH OF THE ONGOING
MONEY IS BEING USED FOR ONE TIME
PURPOSES. FOUR AND A HALF
BILLION WE ARE DEADLINE DOLLARS
WITHIN K. TWELVE EDUCATION SO.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT RAISING THE
BASE. THAT FOUR AND A ALF
BILLION DOLLARS. COULD GO TO
RAISE THE BASE. THAT'S CORRECT
OUR ESTIMATE I THINKWE'VE DONE
IS THAT FOR EACH ONE PERCENT.
INCREASE IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
LCF THAT COSTS SOMETHING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION. HOW MUCH WAS
RIGHT SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION PER SEVEN MILLION 31% OF
THE BASE YEAH. SO THERE'S A
PRETTY HEAVY INCREASE SITTING
OUT THERE. IN THAT FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. SO I HOPE WITH THE
BODY. WILL WELL LOOK TO THAT TO
INCREASE THE BASE AND MAY PUT
THOSE OTHER EXPENDITURES AND
WHAT ARE TRULY ONE TIME MONIES-
SO THAT I APPRECIATE MISTER.
OKAY I DON'T. IT DES THE DOES
THE DOES THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT. THE
VERY FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND DRIVING IT
AWAY. IN SOME CASES FROM THE
CLASSROOM- WOULD BE RATHER
UNFORTUNATE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
SAID DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE AS
TO WHY YOU WOULD SCORE FOUR
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AS
FOR ONE TIME USE IS AS OPPOSED
TO. ONGOING USES. YES CERTAINLY
A AT A AT THE HIGHEST OF LEVELS
YOU KNOW SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM THE- ELLIE- DURING
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THEIR
PRESENTATION. YOU KNOW WE DO
ATTEMPT TO BUILD IN SOME LEVEL
OF ONE TIME RESOURCES OUT OF THE
ON GOING. AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO
BALANCE AGAINST INEVITABLE
DOWNTURNS OR- VARIATIONS IN THE
STATE ECONOMY IN THE FUTURE- AND
THAT IS ONE- TOOL THAT WE CAN
LOOK TOWARD SO. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL- VARIATION IN THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW IT WOULD HELP
MITIGATE- YOU KNOW AGAINST
POTENTIAL CUTS POTENTIAL ACTIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE
TO TAKE- OR COULD HAVE TO
CONSIDER- IN A FUTURE BUDGET.
WELL I GUESS MY RESPONSE TO THAT
WOULD BE. WE HAVE RESERVES OF
THE LOCAL LEVEL. WHICH ARE
HEALTHY. LEVEL AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE THOSE RESERVES- IN TIMES.
AND THOSE ARE NEWER RESERVES
RIGHT FOR THE MOST PART-
OPPOSITION TO ACCEPT HER PASSED
BY THE VOTERS TO ENSURE THAT WE
DO HAVE THOSE RESERVES. AND
WE'VE YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD WERE
SO RELUCTANT TO ADEQUATELY FUND
THE CLASSROOM. BECAUSE OF A
DOWNTURN YEAH WE ALREADY HAVE.
INSURANCE AGAINST THAT DOWNTURN
AND RESERVES- I DON'T THINK THE
VOTERS WHEN THEY VOTED. FOR
THOSE RESERVE SIDE WELL. MAYBE
THEY'LL BELIEVE IN SAVE EVEN
MORE BY CREATING THEIR OWN
RESERVE. BY TAKING ONGOING
MONIES AND PARKING THEM. FOR ONE
TIME USES SO I JUST THINK THAT
THAT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
A RATHER UNFORTUNATE PERSPECTIVE
AND I THINK IT SHORTCHANGES THE
CLASSROOM. YEAH BEFORE YOU GET
TO MISS REYES JUST FOLLOW UP ON
THAT. YOU KNOW. WE HAVE THE BELT
AND SUSPENDERS WITH RECORD
LEVELS OF SCHOOL DISTRICT
RESERVES AND THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DRAW DOWN ON THAT BECAUSE
THEY PUT SO MUCH IN DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND COULDN'T SPEND IT
CAN HIRE PEOPLE. AND THEN WE
HAVE THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE SO WE BUILT THE SYSTEMS
IN PLACE SO WHEN WE GET PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY WE COULD
SPEND IT WE DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE
THAT AN AUSTERITY BUDGET RIGHT
NOW. BECAUSE THE SKY IS FALLING
THAT. IF SOMETHING HAPPENS. WE
HAVE THESE TWO THINGS BUILT IN
SOME. I UNDERSTAND THE
GOVERNOR'S- PRESENTATION THE
OTHER DAY TALKING ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE AT WITH. ONE TIME MONEY
CAPITAL GAINS IN ALICE'S FROM
TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO WHEN THE
DOT COM CRASH BUT AGAIN THAT'S
WHY WE PUT IN PLACE. THE SYSTEMS
TO PROTECT US FROM THERE FROM
THAT AND SO- I THINK AS WELL
HAVE A BIT TOO MUCH IN- ONE TIME
AND NOT ENOUGH AN ONGOING BASED
UPON- THERE NEEDS SENSE YOU KNOW
ONE TIME FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS ONE THING BUT THE
ONE TIME WE PUT OUT ALL THESE
CATEGORICAL THEY ALL SOUND GOOD
BUT IT'S LITERALLY WHAT WE- GOT
AWAY WITH TEN YEARS AGO. YOU
KNOW WE WANTED TO GIVE DISTRICTS
FLEXIBILITY AND FOCUS ON ON
THEIR NEEDS AND EVEN MORE SO.
LLOWED THAT WE'LL GET TO THAT A
SECOND THIS RELAYED THE
GUARANTEE IN NINETY EIGHT. A LOT
OF THE ONE TIME CATEGORICAL
STAFFER FOR THESE IDEAS- WITH
OTHER COMMUNITY SCHOOLS OR WHAT
HAVE YOU THAT ARE GOOD IDEAS BUT
YOU HAVE TO HIRE PEOPLE. AND
DISTRICTS ARE LEERY ABOUT HOW
PEOPLE FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. AND YOU CAN FIND PEOPLE
ALWAYS FOR THAT BECAUSE THE ONE
THEY WANT A FULL TIME JOB SO- I
JUST THINK WE- LEARN THIS
LESSON. AND THE MAX AMOUNT WE
CAN GIVE. TO DISTRICTS WITH
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY- IS THE
PREFERRED OPTION. SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE. FORGET MY QUESTION
I THINK THAT. THE BILL THE STAFF
WANTS FULL TIME. WORK BUT THEY
ALSO WON'T BE PAID PROPERLY. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
REMIND OURSELVES OF THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING PEOPLE TO WORK. TO WE
GIVE THEM FUNDING FOR JUST. ONE
TIME. THEY WANT TO HIRE THE BEST
BUT THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T KEEP THEM OF THE CAN'T PAY
THEM PROPERLY. BUT MY QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN THE ALLEY- REPORT
. ARE YOU SAY THAT THEY PROPOSE
ONE EIGHT ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. SHOULD BE HIGHER
AND YOU SAID THAT THE BACKLOG.
IS LIKELY LARGER THAN THE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION. MY QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE DETERMINE HOW MUCH
LARGER THAT IS AND WHY AREN'T WE
ACCOUNTING FOR IT. YES SO ONE OF
THE WAYS WE'VE TRYING TO ANSWER
THAT IS TO LOOK AT WELL WHAT WAS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. WHAT
DISTRICTS WOULD CONTRIBUTE UNDER
THE HISTORICAL STANDARD WHICH IS
YOU SET ASIDE 3% OF YOUR BUDGET
FOR MAINTENANCE AND WHAT THE
STATE. ALLOWED THEM TO
CONTRIBUTE ABOUT THE PAST TEN
YEARS WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT
LOWER- I THINK MY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE STILL KIND OF
LOOKING INTO THAT. BUT IT SEEMS
TO BE GOING AT FIRST GLANCE IT
THAT'S A BIT LARGER THAT'S MORE
THAN ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION- IN
TERMS OF MONEY THAT. ORDINARILY
WOULD HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE FOR
MAINTENANCE BUT- WASN'T BECAUSE
OF THE FISCAL RELIEF THE
LEGISLATURE. TO PROVIDE. DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION YEARS. YEAH
MMHM MY NEXT QUESTION I KNOW I'M
NOT GOING TO PHRASE IT AS
ELOQUENTLY AS I SHOULD. BUT I'VE
HI RIGHT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
MANY OF OUR- POOR SCHOOLS. DON'T
REPORT WHAT IT IS THEY NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR FACILITIES
ARE SO USED TO MAKING DO WITH
WHAT THEY HAVE. AND THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE MUCH BETTER
. THE MOMENT SOMETHING GOES
WRONG THEY'RE ABLE TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THEY NEED TO
BRING IT UP TO THE LEVEL THEY
HAD TO THAT. IS THERE SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN- THAT WE SHOULD DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THOSE
COMMUNITIES THOSE FACILITIES ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT MOST NEED
IT THEN GET TO THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OR WHATEVER
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO PROPERLY
PRESENT WHAT THEY REALLY NEED TO
BRING THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND BRING THE FACILITIES UP TO
WHERE THEY SHOULD BE. I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I THINK IN
THE NEXT PANEL ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES MIGHT HAVE SOME MORE
COMMENTS BUT- THIS IS OFTEN A
FRUSTRATION THE LEGISLATURE IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A- STATE WIDE
INVENTORY OF THE NEEDS AND KIND
OF FACILITY CONDITION OF
DISTRICTS. THAT SOMETHING- THE
STATE COULD THINK ABOUT-
POTENTIALLY ASKING DISTRICTS
REPORT MAYBE AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING THIS FUNDING- YEAH WE
DON'T HAVE A- LIKE A- SPECIFIC.
RECOMMENDATION AT THIS POINT BUT
IT IS SOMETHING WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT- AND THAT POTENTIALLY
COULD START TO ADDRESS THAT KIND
OF INFORMATION GAP THAT WE HAVE
EVERY YEAR. AND IF I COULD- YOU
KNOW ADD ON TO THE SORT OF
EQUITY LINES THAT THAT YOU-
NOTED MEMBER- I WOULD NOTE THAT-
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
DISTRIBUTE THESE FUNDS. UTILIZES
THE UNDUPLICATED PERCENTAGES THE
END TO PLACATED ENROLLMENT
COUNTS- TO JUST ALLOCATE THOSE
RESOURCES TO DISTRICTS. SO
THROUGH THE ALLOCATION METHOD OF
THAT ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES SHOULD BE
GOING TOWARD. YOU KNOW THOSE
SCHOOL SERVING HIGHEST
PERCENTAGES OF YOU KNOW
UNDERGRAD UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS. MY NOTE THAT IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR I KNOW THAT THAT IS
WHAT WE SHOULD DO BUT TO RIGHT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THINGS THROUGH
INEQUITY LANCE WINDOW. EQUITY
DOES NOT EXIST OFTENTIMES
BECAUSE- THOSE SCHOOLS THAT NEED
IT THE MOST. ARE NOT THE MOST
VOCAL- AND THEY DON'T GET THEIR
EQUITABLE SHARE OF. THAT WHAT IS
NEEDED BY THEM AND WHAT TO IT
THAT THEY COULD BENEFIT FROM
THEIR STUDENTS COULD BENEFIT
FROM TREMENDOUSLY IF THEY WERE
TO RECEIVE. THE EQUITABLE- SHARE
OF THE FUNDING IT'S STILL AN
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS BUT I THINK HAVING A
STATE WIDE INVENTORY. I THINK
WOULD BE A GOOD BEGINNING AND IT
TOO TO PROVIDE THE TRAINING THAT
IS NECESSARY SO THAT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THAT IS NEEDED- SO
THAT WHEN WE MAKE OUR DECISIONS
ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE ARE
TAKING CARE OF THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT FOR TOO LONG HAVE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. ONLY BECAUSE THEY- MAYBE
THEY DON'T FEEL THAT THEY
DESERVE IT OR THEY FEEL THAT
THEY'VE BEEN USED TO DOING WHAT
THEY DID WITH SO LITTLE. THAT
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND-
WHAT WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
PROVIDE. A MORE EQUITABLE SHARE
FOR THOSE THAT MOST NEED IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER. OKAY
SO THAT WAS THE OVERVIEW OF THE
BIG PICTURE PROP NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSAL- WITH REVENUES IN L. C.
F. F. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO PANEL NUMBER TWO WHICH IS-
GOING MORE DETAILED ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION PROPOSAL
SO AGAIN WE'RE GONNA HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF. ANTS AND THEN
ALEJO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
POLICY MR TANG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I WILL BE
GIVING A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION LETTER. STARTING WITH
RESOURCES PROVIDED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISION. THE MAY
REVISION PROVIDES A FIFTY FOUR
POINT FIVE POSITIONS AND THIRTY
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION IN STATE
OPERATIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THIS IS IN ADDITION
TO FORTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND SIXTEEN MILLION IN
STATE OPERATIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT IN GOVERNOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. FOR A TOTAL
INCREASE OF ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE POSITIONS AND FIFTY ONE
POINT SIX MILLION FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. WITH THE ADDITION
OF THESE POSITIONS AND FUNDING A
TOTAL OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX POINT NINE
POSITIONS. AND FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
IS PROPOSED FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. OF THIS AMOUNT.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE PINT
ONE MILLION AND ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY POINT ONE
POSITIONS IT FOR CD HE CITY
HEADQUARTERS. AND ONE HUNDRED
FORTY POINT TWO MILLION AND NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX POINT EIGHT POSITIONS. IS A
SUPPORT THE THREE STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS AND THREE DIAGNOSTIC
CENTERS. THE HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF
THE STATE OPERATIONS PROPOSALS
THERE ARE EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION AND THIRTY SIX POSITIONS
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT VARIOUS
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING OF INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM AND EXPENSE EXPANSION OF
THE UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. ADDITIONALLY FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION EIGHTEEN
POINT FIVE POSITIONS IS PROVIDED
TO SUPPORT EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
INCREASED WORK LOAD IN THE CORE
FUNCTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING WORKLOAD IN ACCOUNTING
OFFICE FISCAL MONITORING UNIT
AND APPORTIONMENT SIENET.
NINETEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION AS
RELATED TO VARIOUS FEDERAL FUND
ATTACHMENTS TO LYING TO THE
AVAILABLE FEDERAL GRANT AWARDS
REFLECT CARRYOVER AVAILABLE FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR. AND TO REFLECT
UPDATED REVENUE ESTIMATE FOR
SPECIAL FUNDS. ONE POINT NINE
SEVEN FIVE MILLION IS FOR
VARIOUS LEGAL COSTS INCLUDING
ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR SETTLEMENTS
. ONE POINT FOUR MILLION IS FOR
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
SUPPORT THE HOLOCAUST TASK FORCE
. THE MAY REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL CHANGES THE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TRAILER BILL
SPECIFICALLY AMENDMENTS TO
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS PARTNERSHIP
ACT PROGRAM. TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. GOLDEN STATE
PATHWAYS PROGRAM KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TRAINING
FUNDING. MULTI LINGUAL LIBRARIES
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION GRANT
PROGRAM EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM AND
LITERACY COACHES AND READING
SPECIALIST GRANT PROGRAM. THE
MAY REVISION ALSO INCLUDES NEW
PROPOSALS FOR TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
TO DEFINITION AND EXPANSION FOR
VARIOUS DEADLINES ENCUMBRANCE
STATES REPORTS AND SUNSET DATES
AND IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR
NEW PROPOSALS AND A REVISION FOR
THE EDUCATOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT GRANT. DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE DISCRETIONARY BLOCK
GRANT AND MANDATES THAT PAYMENTS
. MATH AND SCIENCE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FUNDING COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE EXPANSION
FUNDING AND COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ALTHEA FAITH BASED
INCREASE. DETAILS ON ALL THESE
PROPOSALS ARE REFLECTED IN THE
MAY REVISION LETTER INCLUDED
WITH THE AGENDA AS WELL AS THE
MAY REVISION TRAILER BILL THAT
HAS BEEN POSTED ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WEBSITE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND I ALSO HAVE MY FINANCE
COLLEAGUES AVAILABLE IN THE ROOM
AND ON WEBEX ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON SPECIFIC PROPOSALS.
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION
LETTER THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
L. A. L. GOOD AFTERNOON A GROUP
ROLE WITH THE WITH THE L. A. I'M
I'M GOING TO WALK THROUGH OUR
COMMENTS ON FOUR OF THE
DIFFERENT- K. TWELVE- PROPOSAL
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN DISCUSSED
YET- BUT WE'RE NOT DISCUSSING
HANDOUT. OR- EVERYONE GETS ONE
ONE VARIETY MORE CONTEXT TO.
FIRST ON THE PROPOSAL FOR CHILD
NUTRITION SO THERE'S A PROPOSED
IN THE MIRROR VISION TO INCREASE
THE STATE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
FOR. A TELEVISION PROGRAMS BY
ASSEMBLY SIXTY THREE CENTS PER
MEAL. AND THAT'S INTENDED TO-
PROVIDE OVERALL FUNDING FOR
MEALS- EQUIVALENT TO THE- RATES
THAT WERE PROVIDED DURING-
DURING THE PANDEMIC BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I'M READING
FROM INCREASES IN REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE REASONABLE GIVEN THE
COST PRESSURES THAT NUTRITION
PROGRAMS HAVE FACED OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS- WE DO THINK
OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE A- RECOMMENDATION
DEPENDING ON ITS PRIORITIES. WE
WOULD RECOMMEND ARE REJECTING-
THE ELEMENT OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S TO REALLOCATE ANY UNUSED
FUNDING FOR KITCHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE- EXISTENCE ABOUT
UNSPENT FUNDS WITHIN CAN BE MADE
IN THE NEXT BUDGET CYCLE AND
THERE'S ALREADY FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
FOR KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE MIRROR VISION. ON EXTENDED
AND EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL WOULD ACT-
MODIFY THE JUNIOR PROPOSAL SO
THAT WOULD BE. ONE UNIFORM
FUNDING RATE STRUCTURE OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER- UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE THAT'S
IN GREAT STICKY THREE SIX THAT
MEANS AN ENGLISH LEARNER A LONG
TIME STUDENT. THE THING GREAT
TICKET THREE SIX- WE RECOMMEND
ADOPTING A UNIFORM RATE- HOWEVER
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE DID
MR SHOULD HAVE NOT CHANGED OUR-
TWO TIERED REQUIREMENTS. FOR
WHICH STUDENTS NEED TO BE SERVED
UNDER THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. WE WOULD
RECOMMEND AS WITH A UNIFORMED
FUNDING RIGHT THERE BE UNIFORM
SET OF EXPECTATIONS AND
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMEND. ARE
REQUIRING THAT THAT DISTRICTS
MUST SERVE ANY INTERESTED OUR
LOW INCOME RTL STUDENT. IN THE
DISTRICT- AB BUT NOT HAVE TO
SERVE ALL STUDENTS RIGHT NOW THE
WAY IT WORKS. THANK YOU THE
HIGHER YOU UCBCP DISTRICTS ARE
ARE NOT GETTING MORE MONEY BUT
HAVE HIGHER REQUIREMENTS- IN THE
PROGRAM. I'M AND THEN IN TERMS
OF ARTS AND ONE FUNDING THE
EXTRA LEARNING IN. PROGRAM
THERE'S AN AUGMENTATION IN THE
MIRROR VISION WE CONTINUE TO.
RECOMMEND THAT YOU REJECT THE
ENTIRE AMOUNT. THERE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF UNSPENT
EXPANDED LEARNING FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET BECAUSE WE THINK THAT
THAT. DISTRICTS WILL WILL TAKE
TIME TO EXPAND THEPROGRAM AND
THEY'RE RECEIVING SUCH A FULL
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING. IN THE
COMING BUDGET YEAR SO WE THINK
ANY UNSPENT FUNDS OF THOSE COULD
BE USED. TO COVER THOSE COSTS.
I'M ON THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS RELATED TO
MATH SCIENCE AND EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANTS WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING ALL OF
THOSE- THERE WERE THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET INCLUDE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN.
PROFESSIONAL DAHLE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDING THROUGH THE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANT- THE
CONFUSED OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD AND IN ADDITION. TO ALL
OF THE OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WAS CRIED
DURING THE PANDEMIC CAN BE USED
FOR SO I'M NOT A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL- THE WITH A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE WE DON'T THINK THERE'S
AN I NEED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE. I'M AND THEN FINALLY ON
ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AN ISSUE
THAT WAS. DISCUSSED EARLIER I
THINK I WOULD ADD A LITTLE. MORE
CONTACT ON THE ON HOW WE GOT TO
THE BACKLOG- I'M THIRTY WE'RE
STILL LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
DATA MOVING BACK BUT AND- IT BY
LOOKING AT THE FEW YEARS THAT WE
HAVE- WHEN WE HAVE THESE. LOWER
REQUIREMENTS. IF YOU LOOK TO US
LIKE IT'S SEVERAL HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN LESS SPENDING
THE DISTRICTS HAD ON- ON ON
MAINTENANCE DURING THE PERIOD WE
PROVIDE THE FLEXIBILITY. THE
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN PLACE FOR
ROUGHLY TEN YEARS SO WE THINK
THAT. IT'S VERY. WELL COULD BE
THAT IT'S IN THE MIDDLE MORE IF
MORE THAN TWO BILLION DOLLARS-
TO GET THAT WE'RE STILL LOOKING
AT THE EXACT NUMBERS AND WE CAN.
SHARE MORE OF YOUR MONEY TO SO
THAT'S- PART OF OUR
RECOMMENDATION FOR. WHY WE SAY
YOU CAN DO MORE- TO ADDRESS
THAT. HIGHER HIGHER BACKLOG.
RIGHT ONE OTHER THING I'LL POINT
OUT THAT THE WITH. DIFFERENT
FUNDING WOULD GO OUT IN EITHER
OF THE CASES IT'S BASED ON. THE
DISTRICTS SAYING THESE ARE NEED
SORRY WHAT IT WOULDN'T CREATE-
WOULDN'T CREATE THIS- SYSTEM
WHERE. DEPENDING ON HOW THEY
CLASSIFY THESE COSTS. THEY WOULD
BE REWARDED OR PENALIZED AS A
RESULT SO- BUT WE WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS TO USE- THE NUMBER
OF. THE T. ELLER LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND DISTRICT TO DECIDE
HOW TO ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS. WE
WOULD LIKE TO RECOMMEND USING A
DIFFERENT APPROACH USING LIKE
THE TAXABLE. VALUE OF A STRICT.
IN PROVIDED AMHERST UNTIL MORE
BOB TAX VALUE IN DISTRICT. I WAS
THOSE. GIVE MORE FUNDING THAN
THOSE WITH HARPER TAX BUT
BECAUSE OF. FROM WHY ISN'T THAT
THE MORE DIRECT. RELATIONSHIP
WITH. A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS IF. OFTENTIMES THERE ARE
DISTRICTS HAVE LOWER. PROP VALUE
ARE THAT ARE. MORE CONSTRAINED
IN THEIR ABILITY TO RAISE LOCAL
BOND REVENUE AND THEN HAVE.
HIGHER I MEAN IT'S POSSIBLE TO
FACILITIES. I'M WORKING WITH MY
COMMENTS FROM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY I NEVER GO
BACK TO MR FONG IN A SPECIFIC
QUESTION HERE FOR THESE
PROPOSALS. YEAH. NOTHING TO
SHARE SO MY SPECIFIC QUESTION IS
IT OR THE PACIFIC TOPICAL IN
DISCUSSES THAT STATEWIDE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT DIFFERENTIATED
SYSTEMS WHAT IS THE CURRENT
INVESTMENT IN THAT SYSTEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMBER ALEXANDER-
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THERE ARE- SEVERAL INVESTMENTS
IN THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT AT GLOBALLY BUT THE FOR
THE DIFFERENT SHOULD ASSISTANCE
INVESTMENT SPECIFICALLY. IN
CURRENT YEAR THERE SIXTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION AND IN THE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR THERE SIXTY NINE
POINT NINE MILLION IN THAT
SPECIFIC FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT THEIR
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE WORK.
I'M THERE IS ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
TWO MILLION THAT WE HAVE A BUILT
INTO THE TO THE BUDGET YEAR AS A
PLACE HOLDER IN RECOGNITION OF
THE FACT THAT COUNTY OFFICES
WILL SOON- BEGIN OFFERING. THAT
SUPPORT TO CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED AS BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR DIFFERENT SHOULD ASSISTANCE-
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DASH BOARD IS NOT YET OUT WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY CHARTER
SCHOOLS- WILL WILL KIND OF FALL
INTO THAT TIER. SO WE WILL DO A
CURRENT YEAR ADJUSTMENT IN THE
FALL- WHICH WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT WE TYPICALLY DO TO TRUE UP
THAT DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
THEM OUT TO ENSURE THAT IT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE FULL NUMBER
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED. ZA ROUGHLY.
SIX RECORD TO SEVENTY SIX SIXTY
EIGHT OR AT TO SEVENTY FOR THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
PORTION THERE ARE ALSO OTHER
ENTITIES- THAT ARE PART OF THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT THERE'S THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE. I'M
WHICH IS A ROUGHLY A TWELVE AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT- THERE'S ALSO OUR OUR
PARTNERS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- VARIOUS THAT
DIVISIONS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
PROVIDES SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM. SO IT IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BUT THE
DIFFERENCE IS THE SYSTEMS PEOPLE
ROUGHLY SIXTY EIGHT MILLION TO
SEVENTY SO CERTAINLY A I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS HAS CREATED SIGNIFICANT
ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND NOW IT'S A CAN OF A YEAR
ROUND CHALLENGE- IT HISTORICALLY
I MEAN. I GUESS THE LAST FIVE
YEARS HAS THAT BINDING GONE. OR
BEEN PRETTY. WHAT THE WHAT IS
THE TREND. THAT THE FORMULA FOR
DIFFERENT INSISTENCE IS CALLED
OUT AND STATUTES SO IT'S BASED
ON A THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE-
AND IT'S BASED ON TO BE- THAT
NUMBER OF A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
THROUGH THE DASHBOARD. BECAUSE
THE DASHBOARD HAS BEEN-
OFFICIALLY OFFICIALLY PAUSE
BECAUSE OF- ASSESSMENTS NOT
OCCURRING DURING THE PANDEMIC.
IT HAS BEEN FLAT THESE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE NUMBER OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
FLUCTUATING BECAUSE OF THE
DASHBOARD RESULTS- FOR MANY
FLAT. BUT IN IN THE FUTURE AS-
AS MORE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE IDENTIFIED. THERE
COULD BE FLUCTUATIONS- DEPENDING
ON THOSE DASHBOARD RESULTS. DO
YOU ANTICIPATE A ADDED DO YOU
ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN IN THE SPACE THAT
WE DO- WE DO TRUE UP THE FORMULA
EVERY YEAR AGAIN IT S BASED ON
THAT THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE
SO YOU KNOW ASK THE DASHBOARD-
RESULTS OF PRINT OFFICIALLY
BECOME ON PASTA I'M COMING OFF
OF THE PANDEMIC WE WILL SEE THAT
FLUCTUATIONS IN AGAIN THE
FORMULA WILL TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT BECAUSE IT IS BASED ON A
ROLLING AVERAGE SO THERE THERE
WILL BE I AM NATURAL
FLUCTUATIONS THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. OKAY BUT THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO THE YOU CAN INFUSE
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME MONIES INTO
THIS OR OR WOULD YOU OR CAN YOU
SAID THAT THE STATUTE- IN TERMS
OF THE FOR THE FORMULA IS EFFECT
OBVIOUSLY NOTHING WOULD PROHIBIT
AN ADJUSTMENT- BEING MADE
OUTSIDE OF THE FORMULA- SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR- FOR
LIKE THE CHARTER DIFFERENT
ADDRESSES AND FAT IS OUTSIDE OF
THE FORMULA- AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW MANY ARE
IDENTIFIED I'M RECOGNIZING THAT
IN THE FUTURE IT WILL BECOME
PART OF THAT. DEBT FREE A
ROLLING AVERAGE GOING FORWARD.
OKAY BUT WE SHOULD INFORMATION
THEY GIVE A MUCH. K. QUESTION.
I'LL BE A FEW QUESTIONS TWO
WEEKS AGO WE HAD THE BIG
DISCUSSION ON COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
AND WHAT'S THE REASON RATIONALE
FOR PUTTING THEM INCREASE RIGHT
HERE WE'RE JUST KIND OF ROLLING
IT OUT. I KNOW WE HAVE MONEY TO
SPEND AND TO FINANCE DELEO SAYS
THEY WILL. THAT PRESUMABLY FOLK
BETTER FOCUS HAVE ONE TIME THEN
I'M GOING. TO THE BASE ITSELF WE
HAVE A SLIGHT DISAGREEMENT THERE
BUT SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS FOR
COMMITTEE SCHOOLS. ALL FINISHERS
HANG WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IS BASED OFF OF THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS FROM THE
FIRST ROUND OF PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS WE
THOUGHT. AND HIGH DEMAND FOR THE
IT THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL GRANTS
AND WE ARE ALSO EXPECTING IT
THERE TO BE AN INCREASE IN
INTEREST AND APPLICATIONS FOR
THE FUTURE AROUND THE PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT SO GIVEN
THESE ASSUMPTIONS WE AND- ASSUME
THAT APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IS NEEDED. AND ARE
CONTENT TO WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS TO EXPAND THE ACCESS
TO THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GRANTS
TO EVERY ELIGIBLE ALLOCATE THAT
WISHES TO APPLY. HELLO YES- THIS
IS ONE THAT WE- WE DO WE DO
THINK THAT WE WOULD LOOK AT SOME
OF THEIR THE ESTIMATE THAT
FINANCING IN TERMS OF OUR THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF ED. PUT
TOGETHER IN TERMS OF THE
AFTERMATH. WE DO THINK IT'S
REASONABLE TO EXPECT THAT THAT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME OF THE IF
YOU WANT TO FIND ALL INTERESTED-
SCHOOLS YOU MIGHT NEED TO
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL FUNDING. WE
DON'T KNOW THAT THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION AS OF DECEMBER WE
DO SOME AUGMENTATIONS HERE.
COULD BE- COULD BE REASONABLE TO
ADD- I THINK WE WERE NOT THOUGH
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REDUCE
THAT AMOUNT AND FUNDING FOR
OTHER PRIORITIES. I THINK BASED
ON THE ANTICIPATED GRANT CYCLES
WE DO THINK THAT IF THERE WAS
SOME. ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT
YOU NEED IT WOULD NECESSARY NEED
TO BE IN THE BUDGET YEAR SO YOU
CAN REVISIT THIS NEXT YEAR AS
WELL IF THEIR WORK IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU. WANTED TO-
TO LOOK AT NEXT YEAR WHEN YOU
HAVE BETTER INFORMATION ON THE
NEXT ROUND OF ABOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION WAS ONE WORD. IF
THERE WAS INTEREST IN IN IN IN
MAKING SURE THERE WAS PLENTY
AVAILABLE WE DO THINK. THE
pREASONABLE BUT- IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE RIGHT AMOUNT THERE'S A LOT
OF. A LOT OF A- GIVEN THAT GIVEN
THAT WE'RE STILL EARLY ON IN THE
IN THE GRANT PROCESS. AND THEN-
AS FAR AS THE THAT THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE HOLDING HARMLESS FOR THE
ADDITIONAL YEAR. YEAH THIS IS
BASED UPON THE PREMISE THAT
THERE WAS ONE TIME IMPACT HERE
FOR THE PANDEMIC AND NOT TO BE
CONFUSED WITH THE OVERALL.
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- IN
GENERAL. AND SO THERE WAS ANY
FUSION OF FEDERAL MONEY FOR THAT
SO. WHAT WHY WHY THEY NEEDED TO
GO BACK AND JUSTICE BY CAN'T WE
JUST USE THE PERMITTED.
BASICALLY SOFTEN OUT. THE IMPACT
FOR THE ONE TIME DROP.
RETURNABLE FOR THE FOR THE
HEALTHY OF ATTENDANCE THE- YEAH
I- YEAH I THINK I THINK THE SO
THE DISTRICTS RECEIVE THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT THEY COULD USE FOR
A READY FOR THIS IS IT THAT IS
ALLOCATED BASED ON THE TITLE ONE
FORMULA THAT'S TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN. THE ADDRESSING DECLINES IN
ATTENDANCE I THINK THE WAY WE DO
NOT CONSIDER THAT WE THOUGHT
THAT DEMONSTRATION PROPOSAL WAS
REASONABLE WITH REGARDS TO ALFIE
AFFECTED THAT SUCH A THING.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND YOU BASED
ON. HOW MANY KIDS ARE ENROLLED
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUT
WE'RE GOING TO ASSUME THAT
THEY'RE ATTENDING AT THE RATE
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC THAT SEEM TO US. TO BE
A REASONABLE WAY TO. PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IN A
WAY THAT'S- FILL THE STILL
YOU'RE CONNECTED TO STUDENTS. TO
NUMBER THIRTY THREE BY.
RECOGNIZING THAT THE ATTENDANCE
THIS YEAR IS JUST. YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY LOW IS DOWN. 8%
STATEWIDE- IN THE INITIAL-
ATTENDANCE ESTIMATES. NUTS
BEFORE ON THE GROUND- AND WITH
SO WE THINK THAT. YOU KNOW. WE
KNOW THAT THESE THESE CHANGES IN
ATTENDANCE IN THIS YEAR ARE
REALLY. REALLY DUE TO FACTORS
OUTSIDE OF DISTRICTS CONTROL.
THE FINANCE WHAT TO ADDRESS THAT
IS ACTUALLY WHY THEY NEED TO
PUT. ADDITIONAL MONEY IN HERE
VERSUS. ALLOWING THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO USE THAT ONE TIME
FEDERAL MONEY. TO SOFTEN THE
BLOW.
SO IF I MAY UM CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH FINANCE AGAIN I THINK
THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT THERE'S A
ONE TIME COMPONENT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING OUT FOR- CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE NOT HISTORICALLY HAD
THAT- CAPABILITY A OR THAT YOU
KNOW- ACCESS TO THAT TYPE OF
ADJUSTMENT AND THEN IN THE
ONGOING BASIS. WE'RE REALLY JUST
TRYING TO ATTEMPT TO SMOOTH OUT
DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN
DISTRICTS SO BY APPLYING- THE
ABA STANDARD THAT WE HAVE-
YOU'RE SMOOTHING OUT THE STATE
FUNDING FOR THOSE DISTRICTS OVER
TIME- WITHOUT THAT YOU WOULD SEE
A NATURAL DECLINE IN L. C. F. F.
FUNDING- COULD SOME DISTRICTS
HAVE ACCESS TO FEDERAL RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THAT. YEAH AND IT
IT'S LIKELY THAT THERE MAY BE A
HANDFUL DISTRICTS OUT THERE THAT
DO HAVE- FEDERAL RESOURCES THAT
WERE UP PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO
THEM. THERE WILL BE OTHER
DISTRICTS HOWEVER BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL FORMULA FOR THE PRIMARY
ALLOCATION MR FUNDING RELIED
UPON TITLE ONE COUNTS. THERE ARE
OTHER DISTRICTS THAT DID NOT
HAVE A HIGH TITLE ONE COUNTS
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE- SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCE FEDERAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO TRY AND
MITIGATE. YOU KNOW SOMETHING
LIKE A DECLINE IN- ATTENDANCE.
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY ON THIS
PROPOSAL THIS IS FOR FINANCE FOR
THIS MEAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
AND HOW DOES THAT ACTUALLY-
RECONCILE WITH THE ACTUAL. MEAL
COSTS. YOU'RE LISTENING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
CURRENTLY SCHOOLS ARE RECEIVING
IN THE HANDS RATES AND ALSO ABLE
TO SERVE MEALS TO ALL STUDENTS
WITHOUT COLLECTING ELIGIBILITY
INFORMATION SO THESE TWO WAIVERS
ARE EXPECTED TO EXPIRE AT THE
END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WE
ARE PROPOSING TO BASICALLY BACK
FILLED THAT THOSE FEDERAL
FINANCED RATES- BY INCREASING
THE BASE FOR THE STATE MEAL
PROGRAM SO SCHOOLS CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE SAME LEVEL AS THEY
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WE GET THAT BUT
DOES THAT ACTUALLY JIVE WITH THE
TRUE COSTS. OF WHAT THEY ARE. IT
IS IT WARRANTED FOR THIS
INCREASE I'M OF COURSE WE LOVE
SCHOOL MEALS WE DID LAST YEAR
UNIVERSAL OVER FOR THAT. BUT-
MAYBE IT'S FAR QUESTION FOR L.
A. R. D. IF YOU THINK THAT THIS
WARRANTS THIS INCREASE VERSUS
THE ACTUAL TRUE COSTS I DON'T
THINK WE CAN SPECIFY YOU HAVE A
DIFF IT HAVE TO BE JUST ABOUT WE
DO THINK YOU'RE EVEN BEFORE THE
YEAR BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERE
WAS A PROPOSAL IN. JANUARY
BUDGET TO PROVIDE A MUCH MORE
MODEST ARE INCREASED TO THE
STATE RATE INSIDE THAT TIME WE
DID LOOK INTO A LITTLE BIT OF.
THE PROGRAMAND AT THAT TIME
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME PRESSURES IN THE
NUTRITION PROGRAM BECAUSE AS LCF
IS GROWING SUBSTANTIALLY. AND
STAFF SALARIES WERE GROWING THE
PROGRAM ITSELF WAS ONLY GETTING
COLD SO AT THAT TIME WE THOUGHT
MAYBE IT WAS REASONABLE TO ADD A
TO PROVIDE A RATE INCREASE.
SINCE THEN WE ALSO NOW HAVE- YOU
KNOW. SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
INFLATION WITH REGARDS TO FOOD
PRICES SO THAT'S ANOTHER REASON
TO THINK THAT THAT THAT THE
EXISTING RATES MAYBE- THAT WE
COULD INCREASE THE STATE RATE
THAT TO HELP PROVIDE OF. THESE
COST PRESSURES NOW CAN WE SAY
THAT THE SIXTY SENSE OF THE
RIGHT AMOUNT THAT I THINK IS
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO TELL YOU THAT
THAT'S THE CASE AND THROW UP AND
PER OR THAT WE DO THINK FROM
AUGMENTATION IS REASONABLE BUT-
WE THINK OF THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
PRIORITIES TO. USE THAT FOR
OTHER ONGOING BECAUSE WE THINK
THAT THAT COULD. MAKE SENSIBLE.
OKAY QUESTION FROM COMMITTEE.
FROM THE- PROPOSALS. KEPT SAYING
NINE. ISSUE NUMBER THREE STATE
SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE- SO-
THE- MADE PROVISION PROPOSES SIX
MILLION ONE TIME- GENERAL FUND
AT THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE OVER
A THREE YEAR SO TWO MILLION PER
YEAR FOR THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT
THE SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS-
SPECIFICALLY THESE FUNDS WOULD
YOU KNOW HELP THE- SUMMER SCHOOL
YOU KNOW I'M- MITIGATE- COST
PRESSURES THAT THEY'RE FACING-
IT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL BUDGET
WOULD ALSO HELP THEM- SUPPORT
YOU KNOW SCHOLARSHIPS AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS TO
ATTEND THE SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE
ARTS OVER THE SUMMER- I BELIEVE
THE- TUITION- IF IT MUST BE
PAID. UP FOR STUDENTS. FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS RIGHT NOW- AND SO- THE
INTENT OF THIS PROPOSAL JUST TO
ALLOW THE FROM SCHOOL FOR THE
ARTS TO ENROLL ADDITIONAL
STUDENT SUPPORT THOSE STUDENTS-
WHILE ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THEY
TOO WERE FACING COST PRESSURES.
WE DOMINATE COMMENT ON THIS
PROPOSAL. A SMALL PROPOSAL IN
THE RELATIVE SCHEME OF THINGS
QUESTIONS MISTER DONNA. YEAH I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHAT IS
THIS PROPOSAL I'M STILL A LITTLE
CONFUSED HERE. YOU TALKED ABOUT
TUITION. IS THIS ONE SCHOOL IN
ONE PLACE IS. A GRANT PROGRAM
I'M CONFUSED ABOUT WE'RE GIVING.
WE'RE ALLOCATING IN THE STATE
BUDGET MONEY FOR ONE SCHOOL. TO
HAVE SUMMER SCHOOL. SO AT WHAT
THE SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS
IS ACTUALLY A SPECIFIC PROGRAM
THAT STUDENTS FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE CAN APPLY TO ATTEND
OVER THE SUMMER IT'S DEFINITELY
ARTS FOCUSED- IT I BELIEVE IT'S
A FOUR WEEK COURSE UP FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE ABLE TO ATTEND
I IN ANY GIVEN YEAR THE SUMMER
SCHOOL ATTEMPTS TO I ENROLLED AT
LEAST AROUND FIVE FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS- THERE IS A
TUITION COMPONENT SO THERE THERE
BUDGET IS STRUCTURED SUCH THAT
TUITION COVERS PART OF THE COST.
AND STATE GENERAL FUND FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS DISCOVERED
ANOTHER PORTION OF THE COSTS OF
THEIR IT'S BEEN HISTORICALLY
SPLIT BETWEEN THE TWO IT'S A
RELATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT I
BELIEVE THEIR BASE BUDGET- IN
GENERAL FUND TERMS IS AROUND ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION- IN YOU'LL
THE EACH YEAR SO THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
INTENDED TO YOU KNOW HELP THE
SCHOOL SERVE THAT SAME COHORT
FOCUS ON SERVING. STUDENTS FROM
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES-
SO THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
ATTEND THE SCHOOL- WITHOUT YOU
KNOW HAVING TO SEE THE SCHOOL
INCREASED TUITION OR YOU KNOW
REDUCE ACCESS TO STUDENTS. THIS
IS A PUBLIC SCHOOL. THE CHARGES
TUITION FOR THE SUMMER PROGRAM.
IT'S A IT'S A PUBLIC SUMMER
PROGRAM BUT IT'S NOT A SCHOOL IN
THE TRADITIONAL SENSE THAT WE
THINK OF A YEAR ROUND SCHOOL SO
IT'S NOT SUMMER SPECIFIC IT
THERE ARE FOUR- FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES THAT OPERATE THE
PROGRAM AND SET UP THE SUMMER
PROGRAM AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO ATTEND BUT IT'S NOT
A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL DO WE IS IT
IS IT'S A ONE SITE. RIGHT GOT IT
I BELIEVE IT'S AT ONE SITE- I
FORGET THE EXACT LOCATION I
BELIEVE IT'S SINCE OUTS
FRANTICALLY RITA. OKAY AND- DO
WE KNOW WHAT THE STUDENT
POPULATIN THE STUDENT MAKE UP
IS THERE IS A DIVERSITY. CHOI I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE-
AVAILABLE ON WEBEX BUT I WOULD I
TURN TO YOU ARE THE DIRECTOR OF
THE SUMMER SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS I
BELIEVE THEY ARE ON- AND
AVAILABLE. I CAN HAVE A I DON'T
NEED THAT INFORMATION RIGHT NOW.
I JUST. ASSUME THAT A LOT OF
MONEY FOR A SUMMER SCHOOL
PROGRAM TO ME- AND THE TWO
THIRDS TWO MILLION A YEAR FOR
THREE YEARS. THAT'S CORRECT. THE
TWO MILLION INTO TE TWO
TUITIONS ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND YOU
SAID. YEAH A LITTLE UNDER I
BELIEVE IT'S FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FIFTY PER YEAR BUT WE'LL GET YOU
THE EXACT AMOUNT IT'S JUST AN
AWFUL LOT OF MONEY AN AWFUL LOT
OF STUDENTS. I TO GET YOU UP TO
TWO MILLION I WOULD IMAGINE SO.
YEAH THANK YOU I GET MISTER DODD
I THINK THE THING FOR ME IS LESS
THE ISSUE BUT- PRIOR WITH WE
START TALKING ABOUT A HUNDRED.
PLUS BILLION DOLLARS IN TEN
THOUSAND SCHOOLS NINETY EIGHT
AND WE HAVE TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA AND HERE WE HAVE.
SPENDING OUR TIME TALKING ABOUT
ONE. SCHOOL AND SENATE. IT'S A
ONE OFF IN THE STATE BUDGET AND
I'M NOT SURE HOW THIS CAME ABOUT
BUT- IF I MAY MISTER YEAH. I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE DEATH ONE SCHOOL. IS
GETTING MONEY FOR AN ARTS
PROGRAM. K. TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS
AREN'T GETTING MONEY FOR AN ARTS
PROGRAM. BUT WE'RE DOING A CARVE
OUT FOR ONE SCHOOL. AND I'M NOT
CONVINCED. THAT'S APPROPRIATE. I
MEAN HOW MUCH IS IT NEXT TIME.
AND INTO OUR WE HAVE OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS START PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY COME UP AND WANT
THEIR MONEY FOR THEIR ONE THING.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE. LCF BUT-
I'VE SAID MY PIECE. I WILL SAY
THAT IT WAS YOU KNOW THIS
INVESTMENT WAS PUT FORWARD BY
THE ADMINISTRATION IT IS NOT. A
YOU KNOW A SPECIFIC REQUEST THAT
CAME FROM THE SCHOOL- AND CHEER
CHEER BROADER POINT A BROWNED-
ACCESS TO ARTS AND- MUSIC.
EDUCATION THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PUT FORWARD A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PROP NINETY EIGHT PROPOSAL- TO
SUPPORT ARTS AND MUSIC EDUCATION
THROUGH THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM- AT
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT AND I WOULD. SO THEY COULD
USE THAT MONEY WANT ONE COULD%
ARGUE THAT. I SAID MY PIECE SO
THIS IS SIMILAR TO A MEMBER
REQUEST TYPE THING BUT HE'S HERE
IN OUR CHEN IN TODAY FOR
WHATEVER REASON. BECAUSE THE
MINISTRATION HAS HAS A PRIORITY
IN ITSELF WE GET IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH
THAT THIS THIS IS CONCERNING
ESPECIALLY IF WE DON'T KNOW THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STUDENT BODY
THE GETS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SUCH A PRESTIGIOUS OUR ARTS
PROGRAM THANK ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS WOULD LIKE TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN A PROGRAM WITH
THE TUITION OF ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND- THEY HAVE
THE STATE. SUBSIDIZE IT. ALL THE
STUDENTS IN MY DISTRICT
CERTAINLY DESERVE TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. SO JUST WANTED TO
VOICE MY- WE HAVE MY THOUGHTS ON
THAT WE AGREE. OKAY WE'LL HOLD
THAT ISSUE OPEN. PANEL MEMBER
FOR THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
WHAT IS THE- THREE. OKAY. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AMERICANS ABOUT
THE PERMIT OF FINANCE I'LL BE
COVERING INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER CAREER
PIPELINE AT THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING INCLUDED
IN THE MEMBER VISION THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN INCREASE IN
RESOURCES AT THE COMMISSION OF
ONE MILLION FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
THREE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND
ELEVEN POSITIONS THROUGH THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
FISCAL YEAR AND ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
NINE POSITIONS ON GOING THERE
AFTER TO SUPPORT THE
COMMISSION'S EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PREPARATION AND
LICENSURE. COMMITTEES THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO PROPOSES
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME. TO AUGMENT THE TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT TEACHER AND SCHOOL
COUNSELOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
THIS BUT EXCUSE ME I'M PARKING
UP. THIS FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
FOR ENCUMBRANCE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
MAY BE USED TO ESTABLISH NEW
SCHOOL COUNSELOR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS OR ADD THEM TO EXISTING
TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT THE PREPARATION OF
TEACHERS. AND SCHOOL COUNSELORS
AT THE COMMISSION ART RATHER
SCHOOL COUNSELORS THAT THE
COMMISSION WILL DETERMINE HOW TO
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE COUNSELORS
IN TRAINING- FINALLY- I'M SORRY.
ADDITIONALLY THE EMAIL REVISION
PROPOSES TWENTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME FOR THE COMMISSION
TO SELECT A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY TO SERVE AS A STATEWIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER. TO
SUPPORT TEACHER AND SCHOOL
COUNSELOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER
WILL COLLABORATE WITH THE
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP AND
DISSEMINATE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WITH INPUT FROM INTEREST HOLDERS
TO CREATE A STATE WIDE FRAMEWORK
FOR SUCCESSFUL TEACHER AND
SCHOOL THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AND
SUSTAINABILITY. FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. TO SUPPORT THE
TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO CONTINUE
ADMINISTERING THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER ON TEACHING CAREERS- THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MENTAL NOTE
THAT THE COMMISSION IS ALSO ON
THE LINE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO. FEDERAL
WITH ELEGANT. SO WE ARE COMING
FROM THREE PROPOSALS IN THE C.
D. C. BUDGET FIRST IT'S- WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE PROPOSED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION FOR TEACHER
RESIDENCY GRANTS. AND WE DO WE
DO THINK THAT THE JET OF OUR
DOCUMENTATION IS PREMATURE GIVEN
THAT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION OF THE FUNDING PROVIDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET STILL HAS
NOT BEEN AWARDED- AND WE DO
THINK THAT. INCLUDING FOR THE
NEW SCHOOL COUNCIL RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. WE WONDER WHETHER
WOULD HAVE LIMITED BENEFITS
GIVEN THAT SCHOOL COUNSELING IS
NOT AN AREA WHERE THERE'S A
CHRONIC SHORTAGE- AND WE'RE NOT
SURE IF THERE WOULD BE INTEREST.
IN SCHOOL TO DEVELOP THESE
PROGRAMS GIVEN THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE A- SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGES IN
THIS IN THIS AREA. ON THE
TEACHER RESIDENCY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER WE WOULD-
THOSE LIBERALS TWENTY MILLION
OVER SEVEN YEARS. WE WOULD
RECOMMEND. DOING TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS AND THEN
AT THAT TIME GIVING. LEGISLATURE
OPPORTUNITY TO. REVISIT THAT THE
FUNDING IN DETERMINE WHETHER YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE THAT THE SECOND-
A TEN MILLION DOLLARS IF THE
DEFENDERS EFFECTIVE. AND FINALLY
THERE'S A PROPOSAL- REGARDING- A
READING AND LITERACY STUFF ON
AUTHORIZATION TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVE GRANTS FOR PEOPLE TO
GET THE AUTHORIZATION- WITH
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. WE
THINK FOR. THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- WOULD BE WE ARE WE
THINK IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT THAT
WOULD BE SPENT WE RECOMMEND
REDUCING BY HALF TO SEVEN AND A
HALF MILLION. EVEN WITH THE
THIRD AND A HALF MILLION THAT
WOULD BE ENOUGH TO DOUBLE THE
NUMBER AUTHORIZATION FACT BACKER
THAT DIRECTS YOU TO THE
TYPICALLY. AUTHORIZES OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. I'M BACKING
WITH MY COMMENTS AT ANSWERED.
OKAY THANK YOU A COUPLE. HI HOW
THE GATE SO LAST YEAR WE HAD THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK
GRANT RIGHT AND SO WE HAVE SOME
OF THE SMALLER. PIECES HERE
TODAY AND- WHAT IS BEING-
PURSUED THIS YEAR WHICH COULDN'T
BE- ADDRESSED DURING THE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION WHICH WE
HAVEN'T FRANKLY SPENT. KALLADA
YET. SACRAMENTO FINANCER YEAH
YEAH SO- CHIEFLY AND THERE IS AN
INVESTMENT IN PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN MATH AND SCIENCE-
IT'S A MATH AND SCIENCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVE- I'M SO INCLUDED IN
THAT INVESTMENT IS THREE HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO AUGMENT
RESOURCES TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES FOR PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING- THROUGH THE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANT AND IN
ITS AND SCIENCE AND MATH
PRIORITIZING- THOSE TWO. AREAS
AND- I COULD NOT BE.
ACCOMPLISHED VIA THAT ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FROM LAST YEAR- SO
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
AND- GAVE GAVE. A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY IS THE
DISCRETION TO- PUT PUT THEIR
FUNDS TOWARD THEIR SUBJECT
MATTER AREAS THAT THEY- THEY SAW
FIT- SO THIS THIS IS MONEY
THAT'S THAT'S SPECIFIC TO. MATH
AND SCIENCE TO ENSURE THAT THAT
FUNDING GETS TO THOSE SUBJECT
MATTER AREAS SO WE DIDN'T THINK%
THAT THEY WOULD PRIORITIZE. MATH
AND SCIENCE ACCORDINGLY- ALL
DEFERRED MY COLLEAGUE AMBER
ALEXANDER. AMBER ALEXANDER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YOU ARE
CORRECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
THAT AT THE CORE SUBJECT AREAS
WERE ONE OF THE AREAS OF FOCUS
UNDER THE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS
BLOCK GRANT- TO MY COLLEAGUES
POINT. THERE THERE WERE SEVERAL-
FOCUS AREAS IN WHICH LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES COULD
CHOOSE TO PURSUE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. IN THIS INVESTMENT
IS REALLY TARGETED AT TRYING TO-
INCENTIVIZE AND ENCOURAGE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFICALLY IN MATH AND SCIENCE
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY COULD THEY
COULD HAVE CHOSEN TO PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
THOSE AREAS UNDER THE INITIAL%
INVESTMENT. BUT RECOGNIZING ALSO
THE COMPETING PRIORITIES AND
WANTING TO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS
A SPECIFIC PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OCCURRING IN THE
CORE SUBJECTS. OKAY AND I KNOW
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS HAD A
LOT OF IDEAS AND- WITH A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON WHAT'S THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET PEOPLE IN
THE TEACHER. PROFESSION AND
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD A MAJOR TEACHER
SHORTAGES ATTACHMENT TO MANY-
EMERGENCY CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
IN CLASSROOM THAT YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY HARD PROBABLY A
QUICK TO SERVE OUR ALL OF OUR
KIDS. SO THERE'S A BIG LIST OF
IDEAS WE FUNDED. WHAT IF THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND SOME NEW ONES
THIS YEAR SO ONE THAT HAD BEEN-
ADDRESS OF THE YEARS I KNOW BY
THE COMMISSION AS WELL. IS IT
INTEGRATED TEACHER PREP PROGRAM
SO SENSE STATE. FOUR YEAR DEGREE
ITSELF TO. FOR GO TO GETTING A
JOB BY BORROWING MORE MONEY TO
GO TO- COLLEGE FOR ONE MORE YEAR
AND THEN GETTING A JOB THAT MAY
NOT BE AS MUCH AS YOU WHAT I GOT
WHEN YOU LEFT THE FOR YOU TO
REACH FOR ANOTHER JOB. SO AND I
SHOULD BE AN EFFORT. PRIORITIES
TO GET MORE PEOPLE TO GRADUATE
WITHIN FOUR YEARS SAID. CURIOUS
WHY THOSE TYPE OF- IDEAS. AREN'T
HERE. I'M SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DID INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
INTEGRATED UNDERGRADUATE TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM- BUT THERE'S
MUCH MORE IN MAY SECURES WHY
INDIAN POP UP IN ME. I'LL DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUE AMBER AT AMBER
ALEXANDER AGAIN WOULD DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
AWARE OF THAT THAT CONVERSATION
AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF TAT CONCEPT
AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATION. WITH YOU
AND WHAT THE ASSEMBLY STAFF-
RECOGNIZING THAT YOU KNOW IT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THERE IS- A DESIRE
TO HAVE YOU KNOW LIKE WE INVEST
MORE THAN WHAT HIS PROPOSED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE OF
THE COMMON GROUND AND THAT THERE
IS AN INVESTMENT IN THAT AREA IN
WHICH TO START THE CONVERSATION.
OKAY THANK YOU QUESTIONS MISTER
DONNA I JUST WANT TO JUMP ON
YOUR LAST TOPIC THEY'RE THE
INTEGRATED- PREPARATION PROGRAM
I THINK THE PROBLEM IS THERE
WE'VE GIVEN OUT GRANTS TO
COLLEGES THE PLAN. AND SO
APPARENTLY THEY MET AND PLANNED
. BUT NOTHING HAPPENED. OKAY SO
ANOTHER WORDS THIS OUT AS A
PLANNING GRANT SO THEY HAD
MEETINGS WHEN THEY PLANNED BUT
NOTHING CHANGED I THINK WHAT
WE'RE HAVING IS A SITUATION
WHERE THERE'S SOME RESISTANCE AT
THE AT THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL TO
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS A CHANGE WHEREIN ONE CAN GET
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL INSIDE THAT
FOR YOUR EXPERIENCE SO THAT IS
NEW TO SOME YOU UNIVERSITY
SUMMER RESISTANT. BUT WE STE WE
HAVE THE LAW PASSED FOR A REASON
I WAS THE AUTHOR OF IT. AND WHAT
I'M SAYING IS WE GIVE THESE
AGAIN THESE PLAN GRANTS GO OUT
OF THEIR THERE'S NOTHING AT THE
END THAT WE TOUCH IS NO
TANGIBLES IN OUTCOMES THE A THEY
REALLY SHOULDN'T BE PLANNING
GRANTS THEY SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTATION. GRANTS SO I HOPE
WE CAN CHANGE THE WORDING THE
FOCUS. SO THEIR IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS NOT PLANNING GRANTS. AS
FAR AS I CAN TELL MANY
UNIVERSITIES GOT THE- GOT THE
PLANNING GRANT. I MEAN IT'S NICE
LUNCHES ETCETERA. BUT THEY PLAN
I'M SURE THEY PLAN. BUT THEN
AGAIN WHAT'S THE END PRODUCT
THERE'S NO END PRODUCTS AGAIN.
IMPLEMENTATION NOT PLANNING I
THINK YOU GET IT THANK YOU. OKAY
JOIN RESPOND- YES SO THE TEN
MILLION INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- IS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- BUT I WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND ARE
NOTEDAND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING FURTHER IN BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS. CAN I MISTER YES
SO ONE SO THEY ARE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION- GRANTS. I DON'T
KNOW HOW SPECIFIC THE LANGUAGE
IS. BUT IS THERE GOING TO BE
SOMETHING TANGIBLE THAT COMES
OUT OF A- AT OF THAT GRANTS ARE
THE IS THE UNIVERSITY GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM ARE THEY
JUST GONNA TALK ABOUT IT AGAIN.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE DOES GIVE- THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING QUITE A BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF THAT THE
DESIGN OF THAT PROGRAM I KNOW
THEY- THEY ARE LISTENING I
IMAGINE THAT THEY WILL BE TAKING
THOSE COMMENTS INTO
CONSIDERATION AS THEY CRAFT. THE
PROGRAM ASSUMING THAT IT DOES-
GET GET ADOPTED IN SOME FORM.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO DROP A HAMMER
HERE TO GET THESE PROGRAMS UP
AND GOING- WE'RE CLEARLY MEETING
RESISTANCE AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL BECAUSE IT'S- NOT MAYBE
THE WAY THEY'VE- ALWAYS DONE
THINGS- THE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
SINCE I THINK NINETEEN SIXTIES
SO IT IS A BIG CHANGE. BUT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE NOT JUST TO FILL THE
PIPELINE BUT IT'S- IT'S KIND OF
A NO BRAINER. BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A BETTER PREPARE
TEACHER IF THEY SPEND FOUR
YEARS. TRAINING TO BE A TEACHER
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING. FOUR YEARS
EARNING DEGREE AND THEN ONE YEAR
AFTER THAT- EARNING A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL SO I THINK THERE'S
MANY REASONS. TO- TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE. AND FULLY EMPLOY THE
INTEGRATOR INTEGRATIVE PROGRAM
INTO THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS I
THANK YOU. DAVID OUR RANCHO.
THANK YOU WHAT ARE THE COMMENTS
WAS MADE EARLIER WAS. SCHOOL
COUNSELING IS NOT AN AREA WITH A
CHRONIC SHORTAGE. AND IT WE FIND
THAT IN FACT THERE IS A GREAT
SHORTAGE AND THE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF BILLS AND THE BUDGET
PROPOSALS- ASKING FOR A FUNDING
TO HELP THOSE WHO WANT TO GO
INTO MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS
INCLUDING COUNSELING- I KNOWS OF
SUCH REQUIRES. GENERALLY THIS IS
INCLUDED TO- WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
ALSO AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
AGAIN TO HELP. PROVIDE THE
FUNDING TO HELP THOSE WHO CAN GO
INTO MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS
AND THEN WORK IN THE SCHOOLS. BY
REQUIRE. NONPROFITS BY US- SO
JUST I WANTED TO COMMENT ON THAT
THAT THAT I AM MAYBE- I'VE I'VE
NOTED IT INCORRECTLY BUT THERE
IS A GREAT SHORTAGE OF
COUNSELORS FOR STUDENTS DO YOU
RESPOND TO THAT. I EAT YES I CAN
I CAN RESPOND TO THAT- SO MAX BY
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
THE PANDEMIC I CREATED AN
INCREDIBLE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
BURDEN ON THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND AS AS PART OF A
RECOGNITION OF THAT AND WE ARE
INCLUDING IN THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AUG DOLLAR AUGMENTATION-
FOR THE TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE SCHOOL
COUNSELOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
THAT AUGMENTATION RECOGNIZING
THAT- WE'VE SEEN SUCCESS WITH
THE TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAM
IN- RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION-
AND WE ALSO SEE HIGHER RATES OF
RETENTION WITHOUT PROGRAM. SO
HOPING TO EXTEND THAT TO SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AS WELL. OKAY THE
FURTHER QUESTIONS WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OFTEN. ISSUE FIVE PANEL
FIVE OFF OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. YOU READY MISTER
O'DONNELL. YOU DID DID YOU DID
YOU WANNA GO UP THERE ARE
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF. THE
ASSEMBLY. PHILIP OKAY WELL YEAH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT OUR ASSEMBLY
THE SECOND MISTER GET BERMAN
FINANCIAL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JENNIFER COFFEE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES SHIFTING
THE YEAR OF APPROPRIATIONS FOR
THE ONE BILLION TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED IN 232-422-1224 A TOTAL
OF TWO BILLION ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION- ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO SUPPORT NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS THROUGH THE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
APPROPRIATE ONE POINT TWO
BILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE TO ALSO SUPPORT
NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS THROUGH
THE SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES AN APPROPRIATION OF ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO ADDRESS DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THANK YOU
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. A. L.
EDGAR CABRAL WITH THE L. A. O.
SO WE DO RECOMMEND ADOPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REGARDING
THE SCHOOL FACILITIES- PROGRAM
FUNDING WE DO THINK THAT WOULD
HELP- TO FIND OF. SCHOOLS WE
PROJECT AFTER THE PROPERTY WHAT
BOND FUNDING- IS EXHAUSTED- AS
MY COLLEAGUE CAN COUPON THREE
DIMENSION IN THE PROBLEM NEE OR
YOU DISCUSSION WE DO THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD. DO MORE
TO FUND FACILITIES EVEN WITHIN-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT EITHER
FOR WITH THAT WELL IT IS IN THE
FUNDING FOR THE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM OR- ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR D. K. IMPLEMENTATION- TAKEN
WITH MY CLIENTS. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
MISTER TRIED UNITED SAID EARLIER
AND THAT IS THAT WE NEED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE OUR
COMMITMENT TO SCHOOL FACILITIES
THE AVERAGE SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES OVERSIGHT SKIERS ALL
OVER SIXTY YEARS OLD- IN MANY
ARE NEED OF GREAT REPAIR
MODERNIZATION EXEDRA AND AGAIN
AS I ALLUDED TO EARLIER ALSO.
THE AVAILABILITY OF SCHOOL
FACILITY FUNDS AND ULTIMATELY
IMPACTS THE PRICE OF HOUSING NEW
HOUSING SO THAT'S A THAT'S A
THAT'S A BIG DEAL. SO AGAIN- WE
HAVE WHAT ARE LEFT ARE THE
SIMPLY PLAN CALLS FOR TEN
BILLION. RIGHT TEN BILLION NINE
NINETY EIGHT ONE TIME PAYMENT.
ON FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES- I
STAND BY THAT COMMITMENT I'M
SURE YOU DO MISTER CHAIR. AND I
KNOW THIS IS A PROCESS I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY. WHEN I CANNOT IMPORT
PUNYA MORE- THAT WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES THIS IS
OUR CHANCE. WE HAVE A LOT OF ONE
TIME MONEY OUT OF NINETY EIGHT
AND WE CAN DO IT AND SO- I KNOW
WHAT WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE
TODAY. I WILL BE WORKING TOWARDS
THAT GOAL. SO WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION. THINK ABOUT THE-
THE DEMAND OUT THERE. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO MODERNIZE AND
BUILD. NEW CLASSROOMS. WHAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE. PRIOR BONDS AND-
WOOD OBVIOUSLY PROP THIRTEEN
DIDN'T PASS AND WE HAVE. SOME
ONE TIME MONEY HERE. HOW DOES
THAT. HOW DOES THIS ALL CONTENT.
CONNECT YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION ARCHER MCCARTY
SO ARE A PROPOSAL FOR THE MAY
REVISION REALLY FACTORS IN
CONSIDERATION OVER OF THE
REMAINING PROJECTS THAT- ARE IN
THE QUEUE CURRENTLY FOR THE
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM AS WELL
AS FACTORING IN YOU KNOW IN CASE
OF EMERGENCY PROJECTS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY COME UP- AND THE
INCREASE IN THE- CONSTRUCTION
COST INDEX- SO WE REALLY
FACTORED INTO OUR PROPOSAL AND-
THIS IS A THIS IS A SIZEABLE
PROPOSAL OF FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD ON TOP
OF THE PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
REMAINING BONTA THIRTY OF ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. OKAY. QUESTIONS OKAY SAYING NINE AND
NEXT WE HAVE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES.
SHE YEAH RIGHT. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A DEPARTMENT. AND L. A. M.
OKAY OUR MISSILE SERVICES PLEASE
PRESENT GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LOOK
BEHIND MY LAMB AND I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT DIVISION FOR
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES I WILL BE PROVIDING
EIGHT OVERVIEW OF THE MAY
REVISE. THIS PROPOSED MAYBE VICE
REFLECTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTING AND ALL THE COMPONENTS
OF THE MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM.
GUIDED BY THE MASTER PLANNED FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE THE
BUDGET PROPOSES IT INCLUDES SIX
POINT THREE BILLION FOR CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS INCLUDING CONTINUE
SUPPORT FOR THE HISTORIC MULTI
YEAR COMMITMENT. IT ALSO
CONTRIBUTES TO THE COMMITMENTS
TO EXPAND CHAO PER AXIS BY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND I SLOPS BY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
HEALTHCARE WAIVERS ARE ONE OF
THE COMPONENTS THAT ARE IN THE
MAY REVISE THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES ONE THIRTY SIX MILLION
AND ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS TO
EXTEND FAMILY P. WAIVERS FOR
STATE SUBSIDIZED HEALTH CARE AND
- PROGRAM. FROM TWO. TWENTY TWO
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY THREE.
ALSO WE HAVE HOLD HARMLESS WHICH
IS REIMBURSEMENT FOR. AUTHORIZED
HOURS OF CARE THIS PROPOSAL
EXTEND THE REIMBURSEMENT OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS FOR
AUTHORIZED HERE. OR AUTHORIZED
HOURS OF CARE RATHER THAN ACTUAL
HOURS OF CARE FROM JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN MILLION FUNDS AND ONE.
EIGHT ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS TO
DO SO. CHAU CURRENT DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
AUGMENTATION. THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED POINT FIVE%
MILLION. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE FOR MINOR RENOVATION AND
REPAIRS FOCUS ON CHILDCARE
DESERT AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. JUST A COUPLE MORE-
THE ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
CAPACITY GRANT THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES TWENTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO ASSIST ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS AND DEVELOPING CAPACITY
TO SERVE ADDITIONAL SLOT
COMMITMENTS. AND THE CHOKER
SLOTS AND THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDES NINE NINE TWO MILLION
TO ANALYZE THE CHILD CARE SLOTS
BEING ADDED IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWO
SEVENTY MILLION FOR POKER SLOTS
TO BE ADDED IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
ESTIMATED THIRTY SIX PER YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE BRINGING
TWO ONE FORTY SIX ADDITIONAL
SLOTS AND ALL TOWARDS THAT
ULTIMATE GOAL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND BY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX. THIS THINK TANK. HI
OVERVIEW CHIEF DEPUTY CHEN CHOI
R. AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND MYSELF ARE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK. DID YOU WANNA GO GEN-
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS- YES SORRY
GARRISON TOWARD PERMANENT
FINANCE- NOTHING TO ADD BUT
HAPPY TO HELP AND ANSWER NY
QUESTIONS NO I MEAN. YEAH GET
ELIA RODEOS HAVE A COMMENT ON A
COUPLE OF THE OF THE PROPOSALS-
FIRST OF ON THE ON THE HOLD
HARMLESS FOR- CON CONTRACT
PROVIDERS WITH THIS APPLIES TO
BOTH THE GENERAL CHUCK REPORT
PROGRAM WITHIN DFF AND ALSO THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
UNDERSTANDINGS OF THEIR SIMILAR
PROPOSALS ON OUR ABOUT US PEGS.
I'M HAVING A HOLD HARMLESS
WITHIN THE DOES PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR CHARTER AND PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS- BUT WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER
IMPLEMENTING A MULTI YEAR PLAN
TO TRANSITION FUNDING TO BEING
BASED ON ENROLLMENT IN THE
FUTURE I'M WITH A MULTI YEAR
PLAN CHUKKER PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS
CONNECT PETITIONS ARE TO HELP.
BRING THEM TO OF CHILDREN OF THE
TO THE PANAMA AND ACTING JUST
POLICY FOR ONE YEAR JUST
CONTINUES AND CERTAINLY IN THE
LONG TERM- DIDN'T A SECOND AB.
CAPAZ GROUND STILL LOOKING THE
ISSUE AND TRY TO GET A MORE
FROM- FROM THE MISTRESS ON HOW
THE TWENTY DOLLARS WAS
DETERMINED. A BOY WE WOULD NOTE
THAT IF YOU DIDN'T THESE ARE
THEY RECEIVE SEVENTY BY SEVENTY
POINT 5% OF THE COST OF EVERY
THOUGHT IN THE IF YOU PROGRAM
THE SPEECH TO SPEECH THREE
PROGRAM IS FOR. ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT SORT THE. AND ARE
TWENTY. THE AP VAULTERS BY
PETITIONS I'M WITH MY COME I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER. OKAY SO THERE'S
ALWAYS A LOT OF ATTENTION THIS
TOP OF COURSE SAID. CHILD CARE
YEAH AFFORDABILITY ACCESS AND A
BIG PIECE OF THE PUZZLE OUR
RATES I KNOW SUMMER REYES HAD
AND I AM WORKING ON THIS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND COURSE WE
HAVE CONSTANT ATTENTION HERE
INCLUDING A BIG RALLY- TODAY
AND- I GUESS THE QUESTION IS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND D. DO
YOU THINK AND THE PARCEL
SERVICES DO YOU THINK THE
CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE IS
ADEQUATE. TO ENABLE THE FIELD TO
DO THEIR JOB AND A FUNCTIONING
CALIFORNIA. DO WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. I'M MAJOR
TOMORROW WEBER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THE MAY REVISION
REFLECTS THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURE THAT WAS AGREED TO IN
THE FIRST COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT REACHED BY THE STATE
AND CCP LAST YEAR AND THE MAYOR
VISION ALSO REFLECTS THE FUNDING
FOR SUPPLEMENTS TO THE RATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR THAT WERE
AGREED TO ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE TRUCTURE
SUBJECT TO FUTURE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS BUT WE ALL
. REFORM IS CURRENTLY BEING
PURSUED AS CONSISTENT WITH THE
AGREEMENT THE STATE AND C. C. P.
YOU ARE WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
THROUGH A JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE ARCHDALE NC TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A SINGLE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE
THAT ADDRESSES QUALITY STANDARDS
FOR EQUITY AND ACCESSIBILITY
WHILE SUPPORTING POSITIVE
LEARNING AND DEVELOPMENT
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN. THE JONES
HE WILL PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
NO LATER THAN NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AND
STATES ALSO CONVENING A SEPARATE
WORK GROUP TO ASSESS THE
METHODOLOGY FOR ESTABLISHING A
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND EXISTING
QUALITY STANDARDS FOR CHILD CARE
AND DEVELOPMENT PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND NETWORK GROUP WILL
PROVIDE STATION LATER THAN
AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. AT I GET ALL THAT
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR STATEMENT
YOU READ ELOQUENTLY- BUT THE
QUESTION IS. NOW THE GOVERNOR
HAD A MASTER PLAN EARLY
EDUCATION EVEN WORKING ON THIS
AND WE SIGNED THE CONTRACT- LAST
YEAR BUT DO WE THINK THE RATES
ARE ADEQUATE. TO SUPPORT THE
CHILD CARE NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY DO WE THINK THERE ADEQUATE
. YES OR NO. I THANK YOU CHAIR
GARY CENTER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- TO SORT OF ELABORATE ON
MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS I THINK
THAT WE ARE IN RECOGNITION THAT-
THAT THE- THERE IS MORE WORK TO
DO AND THIS AND IN THIS ARENA
REGARDING A REIMBURSEMENT RATES
THAT IS RECOGNIZED IN THE FIRST
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
THAT WAS REACHED LAST YEAR WHERE
WE HAVE IN PLACE AN INCREASE IN
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND ENDED IT
IN ADDITION TEMPORARY
SUPPLEMENTS TO THOSE RATES- BUT
WE ARE LOOKING FOR THE WORK THAT
IS BEING DONE THROUGH THE JAIL
AND SEE AND THE WORK GROUP. TO
FURTHER LOOK INTO WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO HAVE A SUFFICIENT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM THANK
YOU AND GETS BETTER ANSWER- BUT
THE BIG PICTURE IS THAT THERE'S
THAT THE COUNTRY IS ONE AND I
BELIEVE THAT OF THE CHILD CARE
AND STATE PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS
THAT THAT CONTRACT. DOESN'T
IMPACT- THIS. COURSE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THIS COURSE YOU KNOW.
PUBLIC CHILD CARE- PROVIDERS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ALSO ARE
BASED UPON THE SAME
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND- AND YOU
KNOW. WE SEE EVIDENCE ALL THE
TIME E SEE THE INFLATION GONE
UP AS WE TALK ABOUT K. TWELVE
TREMENDOUSLY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND- IT DOESN'T PENCIL OUT
THAT'S WHY DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE SAW. JUST CLOSE NOT RICH IN
MINIMUM WAGE HAS GONE UP AS WELL
SO WE DON'T WANT TO PAY PEOPLE
YOU KNOW LIVING WAGE IS NOT
PARTY WAGES. AND SO WE'RE NOT-
DONE WITH OUR GREAT REFORM AND
RATE REIMBURSEMENT INCREASES AND
SO. THAT'S A PRIORITY OF THE OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND JUST WANTED
TO FOR THE RECORD HERE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS ABOUT THAT
I KNOW YOU WANT TO DO MORE
RESEARCH AND STUDY ON IT BUT I
THINK ALL THE- SURVEYS THAT
WE'VE DONE TO DATE. SHOW THAT
IT'S INADEQUATE. I'M IF THE IF
THE THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
WERE AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THEM- I THINK THAT WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT THAT THERE IS MORE
WORK TO BE DONE AND WE WOULD.
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
ARE LOOKING INTO YOU HAVE THAT
THE EXISTING COMPLEXITIES AND
HOW THINGS ARE WORKING WITH
REIMBURSEMENT TO MAKE THOSE MORE
SIMPLIFIED MAKE THEM WORK BETTER
FOR THE FIELD. AND DO THAT
THROUGH THE CITY ON C. AND WORK
GROUP SO. IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT TO SEE
THROUGH THIS WORK AND- THE- MOVE
THROUGH THROUGH THE NEXT BY THE
BUDGET CYCLE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW TO- AND ADDRESS IMPROVED
REIMBURSEMENT RATE STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU SUMMER RACE. I'LL SHOW
THIS. WEEKEND THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE. IF WE'RE LUCKY THE
FLOTATION RATES. HERE THAT WE'RE
JUST PROVIDED TO US EARLIER WE
ALSO HAVE A FOUR YEAR OLD RATE
STUDY. HAT GIVE US A BETTER
IDEA. LOTS OF MONEY SPENT BUT
THAT'S THE STUDY THAT SURVEYED
TOGETHER. AS WAS MENTIONED BY
THE CHAIR. AND THEN ALSO THE
STRESSES OF PANDEMIC AND WHAT
THAT MEANS THAT THE MOST RECENT.
CHILD CARE FACILITY THE CLOSES
THE CAPITAL. CAPITAL CHILD CARE
FACILITY. AND THEY'RE NOT BEING
REPLACED AND WE HEAR THIS OFTEN.
AND WE KNOW IT'S TRUE WE'RE NOT
PAYING OUR WORKERS WHAT THEY
DESERVE. THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF
OUR CHILDREN THE MOST PRECIOUS
THING THAT WE HAVE. AND YET. WE
PUT TOGETHER A STUDY THAT SAYS
THE MORE WE'RE LOSING THEM
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BEING PAID
ENOUGH THEY'RE SAYING PAY US
MORE. AND YET WE COME TO THE END
AND WE DON'T PAY THEM MORE- THE
THEY ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE WHOLE SCHEME
OF THINGS OF HOW WE WANT-
ORDERED. THE TO PROVIDE THE
EDUCATION PROVIDE THE CARE FOR
CHILDREN AND- I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH THE CHAIRED SOMETHING THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED WE
STILL NEED TO LOOK AT THAT- AND
I RECOGNIZE. THAT YOU KNOW YOU
YOU PREFER TO THE- FIRST
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
WE GET IT. BUT IF WE KNOW THAT
IT ISN'T ENOUGH THEN WE DO HAVE
THAT OBLIGATION TO REVIEW IT
FURTHER. I WANTED TO ASK IF I
MAY- SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
FAMILY FEES WAIVER AND LYFT. SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GOVERNOR THANK
YOU TO. TO THOSE WHO HAVE WORKED
SO HARD FOR THAT. IT IS A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION. AT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION. CAN YOU
BREAK THAT DOWN FOR US PLEASE
WHAT IS THE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION- I'M SURE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AB
JUST TO CLARIFY- THE TOTAL
PROPOSED FUNDING TO EXTEND THE
FAMILY FEE WAIVERS AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR IS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION- THIS IS THIS IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE- PROJECTED
NUMBER OF FAMILIES WHO WITHOUT
THE WAIVER. WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO- PAY A FAMILY FEE
THAT WE WOULD WE WILL BE
COVERING ON THEIR BEHALF. AND
THE FEDERAL FUNDING OF THE
FEDERALLY WE CAN EXTEND IT
FURTHER. AND THE I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THAT WE CAN EXTEND IT.
INTO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- AND
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE
ABSOLUTELY SHOULD LOOK AT SO
THAT OUR CHILD CARE FACILITIES.
CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS WITHOUT
HAVING TO THINK MY GOODNESS NEXT
YEAR WE GOT TO GET STARTED WITH
THIS AGAIN AND WE'RE HIGHER.
LONGER KEEP THEM AND- IF. WE
HAVE THE- TO EXTEND IT FURTHER.
AND WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD- SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE OUR CHILD
CARE WORKERS AND ORGANIZATIONS
HAVING TO COME BACK. YEAR AFTER
YEAR WHEN WE HAVE THAT ABILITY
IN THE VERY LEAST FEDERALLY TO
EXTENDED ANOTHER YEAR BEYOND
THAT- I WOULD THE APPS THAT WE
LOOK AT THAT VERY SPECIFICALLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER. SO
BACK TO THIS- BACK TO THAT THIS
THE STUDY THAT YOU MENTIONED-
DON'T WE ALREADY HAVE IN STATUTE
WHERE WE SAY WE SHOULD BE AT
THIS EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE AND
WERE BELOW THAT BY TEN POINTS OR
SO SAYS AND THAT THE STUDY THAT
WE HAVE TODAY AND THEY WERE NOT.
FOLLOWING THAT TO FIND. OUR
CENTER BASED AND FAMILY BASED
CHILDCARE AND PRE K. PROGRAMS-
YES OF WHAT WAS REFLECTED IN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND ADOPTED INTO STATUTE WAS AT
THE S. SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
AT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARMOR
SURVEY I GET THAT BUT AGAIN OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE COVERED. TO
THE CONTRACT WHICH WE 100%
SUPPORT I THINK THAT'S MAYBE L.
L. CAN HELP US LIKE LESS THAN A
QUARTER OF PEOPLE AT LESS THAN A
QUARTER OF WHAT IS- UTILIZE WITH
OUR REIMBURSEMENT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. A DIGNITARY
REFERRING TO IS I THINK THERE'S
INTENT LANGUAGE IN STATUTE THAT
SAYS THAT THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET ULTIMATELY
GET TO GET PROVIDERS TO THE
EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WAS ADDED
AFFECTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE
HAVE NOT GOTTEN CLOSE TO DOUBLE-
AT THIS POINT WE'RE AT SEVENTY
FIFTH OF THE RETAIL MARKET RATE
LAST YEAR THERE WERE THERE WAS
PROGRESS IN THAT- THE COUNTRY
PROVIDERS THAT WERE UNDERSTAND
REIMBURSEMENT RATES HAVE NOW
MOVED ON TO THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATE AND MANY OF THEM WERE VERY
FAR BELOW THAT THE- REASON ORDER
HAVE MOVED UP BUT STILL. THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ALONG WITH THE-
MODIFIES THE EIGHTY FIFTH OF THE
OF THE RELIGIOUS REMIND US TO
OVERALL THE STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE PAID FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL. CHILD CARE. THERE'S
FUNDED AND FAMILY TO CARE HOME.
CORRECT BACK AND SO. THIS THAT
THE CENTERS THAT ARE HERE AROUND
TOWN MAYBE EVEN HE ONE HERE
DOWNTOWN THAT. FAMILIES THAT USE
SUBSIDIZED CARE. THEY'RE NOT
PART OF A CONTRACT RIGHT. SO
THAT WE KEEP FOCUSING ON THAT
THE FOLKS WHO ARE. IMPACTED BY
THIS CONTRACT BUT REMIND US
AGAIN HOW MUCH OF THE OVERALL.
PIES THAT ALTHOUGH I THINK IF
THE I AM. NOT SURE I THINK THE
GENERAL IN TERMS OF OVERALL
AMOUNT I BELIEVE THAT JOHN
TUCKER IN THE- IF YOU PROGRAMS
MAY BE. FROM A SIMILAR BUT MOST
OF OUR GREAT MOST OF THE SYSTEM
WHEN YOU INCLUDED EIGHTY PROGRAM
THREE MOST ARE SUBSIDIZED DR
SYSTEM IS VOUCHER IS. SO
FAMILIES OF THE ROGERS. THE
PRIVATE- SO THESE ARE THE
PROVIDER IS A FAMILY SHOW. THE
BECAUSE I'M A VOUCHER THEY GET
THEIR THEIR- THE COVERED- THOSE
ARE ALSO THE FUNDED BASED ON
REGIONAL MORE RATE IN THE THIRTY
FIFTH. OF THE- MARK. TO VERY
THERE IS THERE- BIGGER WE ARE
USING. WE'RE USING THE SEVENTY
FIFTH AND IF OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SURVEYS SO WE ARE ALSO
SEVERAL YEARS BEHIND TERMS OF
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW. YES THEY
WERE USING A FOUR YEAR OLD
SURVEY WHICH WE KNOW IS
INADEQUATE AND WE'RE- WELL BELOW
THAT. SO WHAT'S THE NEED TO GO
AND STUDY AGAIN WE'RE NO WE'RE
NOT. WE'RE NICK WE KNOW WE'RE
NOWHERE CLOSE TO. ADEQUATELY
FUNDING WHERE WE SHOULD BE I
GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION BY.
NAME MY- YARD. RICK. THREE THREE
THAT I THINK WILL THE LADY
BECAUSE OF PANDEMIC BUT- SHE- BE
OUR- COMING IN FROM POINT. TO SO
ARGUMENTS TO AS A SET TO AND
THANK YOU TAKING THE NEW
POSITION CALIFORNIA. HOW DO YOU
VIEW THE THAT OF THE FIA FIELD
WITH WE READ REPORTS ALL THE
TIME WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
PUBLIC COMMENT A LITTLE BIT.
ABOUT HOW THIS. CRUMBLING AND
FRAGILE SYSTEM OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AS A FAMILY
MEMBER REYES SAID WE SEE IT NO
FURTHER THAN ACROSS THE STREET
OUR OWN CENTER HERE JOT DOWN. SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
BASED UPON THIS CURRENT BUDGET
THERE ISN'T A PENNY AND IN
ADDITION TO INCREASE RATES AND
SO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
FURTHER STABILIZE OUR OUR CHILD
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY- AND I CAN
LOOK BEHIND ME MY LOVE- DEBBIE
DIRECTOR- AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
I COULD TELL YOU THAT ALREADY
THE- FEDERAL EVEN PRIOR. AND
DEMOCRATS SO PRIOR TO THAT
PANDEMIC WE ALSO HAVE WITH THE
SYSTEM ITSELF WAS QUITE FRAGILE
WITH THE PANDEMIC OBVIOUSLY IT
IS STARTING TO REALLY BECOME
EVEN MORE FRAGILE AND WE HEAR
THAT WE HEAR FROM THE STAKE
HOLDERS WE HAVE MEETINGS WITH
WITH THEM FREQUENTLY AND HEAR
WHAT IS HAPPENING BUT WE CAN SAY
IS THAT THE MULTI YEAR INVEST.
FOR ONE TWENTY TWO THAT CLOSELY
BEEN THROUGH TWENTY THREE THAT
MANY OF YOU WERE CHAMPIONS AT
THAT IS A FIRST START FOR THAT
WE KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT THE
ONLY STEPS THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT AND I
THINK THAT THE PERMANENT FINANCE
CALLED THAT OUT ALSO BUT WE KNOW
THAT THAT WAS A BIG LEAP WITH
THAT NOW THE RATE REFORM GROUP
THAT WE ARE HAPPY AND THAT IS
PART OF A WORK GROUP THAT'S MADE
UP OF NOT ONLY WORKGROUP MEMBERS
THAT ARE STILL. OUT AND THE
PEOPLE THAT. BUT JUST HOW- AND
OTHER. I ARE REALLY MAKE. A
DIFFERENCE IN REGARDS TO BOISE
IN WHAT IS THIS NEW SYSTEM- WHAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS WHAT I
APPRECIATE ABOUT THE GROUP IS
THAT THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
WHICH WAS WHAT. AND THERE WAS
FOR IT REFERENCING IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE LOOKING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY WE'RE LOOKING THAT
UP NOW TURNED IT UP METHODOLOGY.
THAT'LL TURN A METHODOLOGY
LOOKED TRUE COST OF CARE. I
THINK THAT IN ITSELF IS
SOMETHING THAT'S CONTRIBUTING TO
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE PLANNING
TOGETHER ONCE WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE STEPS- AND THEN WE TO CAN
GET STIPENDS WE HAD SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN STATEMENTS THAT
WERE. SUPPLEMENTAL IT'S TO OUR-
YEAH I'M WORKFORCE SO YES WE
HAVE READ FOR. WE HAVE. INCREASE
AN- BUT WE- HAD SUPPLEMENTAL TOO
SO. THAT AND THAT WENT TO THE
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM SO NOT ONLY
DID IT GO TO OUR STEPS AND. AND
EVEN IF SYMPATHY FOR THE STATE
BUT IT ALSO IN. A REVISED THIS.
MAYBE SERVING A 100% UNTIL. SO
IT WAS AN ATTEMPT TO BE ABLE TO
AT LEAST PROVIDE ONE STEP TO
SUPPORT THE FIELD DURING THESE
I'M PRESIDENT TIMES YEAH. SO THE
FAMILY FEES ARE A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE IN. THE SUMMER RACES BEEN
CHAMPING THIS AND WE'VE BEEN
SUPPORT OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
TO. WAIVE THEM AND GET RID OF
THAT CAN BE IS JUST GET THEM. IT
THAT PERFECTLY STYLE TO KEEP
COMING BACK TO THIS. BUT THE A
PIECE OF THE PIE. EVEN IF THEY
ARE. IF THEY'RE WAY DOWN THERE
YOU KNOW SOMEHOW AFFORDABLE THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO FIND A
SPOT. AND BARS I HEAR A DOWNTURN
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO WHAT
ARE THE SHUTTERED LOCATIONS
TELLING YOU. OUR DEPARTMENT OR
CALIFORNIA WHAT WE NEED TO DO
WHAT THEY TELL US ALL THE TIME
IS. IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WHY
WOULD YOU OPEN A BUSINESS
WHETHER IT'S A SANDWICH SHOP A
DRY CLEANER ANYTHING ELSE FOR
YOUR- REVENUE COMING IN DOESN'T
EQUAL THE COSTS. YEAH KEEP IT TO
OPERATE AND MAKE IT ALL GOES
BACK TO THIS. RATE STRUCTURE SO. I ARE I AM AM I MISSING
SOMETHING. I THINK I WOULD CREE
EMPHASIZE AGAIN WHAT WE
CURRENTLY ARE- IMPLEMENTING THIS
CURRENT YEAR AS WELL AS WHAT WE
PROPOSE LIKE YOU'VE MENTIONED-
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A HOLD
HARMLESS AN EXTENSION WHICH YES
I BELIEVE THAT THE FAMILY FEES
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO WAVE OFF
OF TO WAIT BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
HOLD HARMLESS. HOLD HARMLESS
SPECIFICALLY MEANS THAT THESE
SITES ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE YOUR- AND REIMBURSEMENT-
AND SO IT'S NOT SO MUCH BASED ON
ATTENDANCE BUT BASED ON- BUT
BASED ON ENROLLMENT THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP STABILIZES
THE FIELD TOO SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PIECE THAT IS PART OF THIS
BUDGET THAT HAS BEEN EXTENDED
FOR ONE MORE YEAR. BUT AGAIN
WE'RE WORKS CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE BECAUSE
WE KNOW WE HAVE SOME WORK AHEAD
OF US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MEET
OUR LONG TERM GOALS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE MASTER PLAN.
OF EARLY LEARNING. SO AGAIN WHO
WHAT ARE THE CENTER IS TELLING
YOU. THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO
. IS THIS IS IT ARE THEY TELLING
YOU THE SAME THING THEY TELL US
THE RATES SO THE CENTERS ARE
TELLING US QUITE A FEW THINGS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE CENTERS WITH THE
HOLD HARMLESS RIGHT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE TITLE FIVE
CENTERS WERE CALLING I THINK WE
HEARD IT IN THE STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK AND WE ALSO HEARD IN
THE LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS AND WE
ALL RECEIVED. LETTERS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT AND THIS MAY
PROPOSAL- ADDRESS THAT AND THAT
TOO WE ALSO HEARD FROM OUR RATE
REFORM WORK GROUP IN REGARDS TO
THE LOOKING AT THE RATE
STRUCTURE AND THE RATE REFORM
WORK GROUP HAS. COME IN FOR
THEIR COMEDY AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE OTHER ALTERNATE
METHODOLOGY AND BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT TO COST OF CARE SO WE'RE ALSO
HEARING ABOUT THAT ALSO SO
THERE'S DIFFERENT PIECES THAT
ASK FOR HEARING WERE ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER
TO BE ABLE. TO THINK ABOUT THIS
LONG TERM SYSTEM. OKAY ACTIMIZE
RACE. JUST PUTTING THINGS INTO
PERSPECTIVE WHEN THE STUDY WAS
DONE FOUR YEARS AGO IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE MINIMUM
WAGE IN CALIFORNIA WAS ELEVEN
DOLLARS PER HOUR. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO MINIMUM WAGE IN CALIFORNIA'S
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR. THAT'S
A 27% INCREASE JUST IN THE COST
OF WORKERS' SALARIES. AB WE ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDING IT AT THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- IF THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROPOSES ANOTHER
INCREASE TO FIFTEEN FIFTY PER
HOUR WHICH BRINGS THE INCREASE
TO THIRTY PERCENT. TOTAL. THE
MAY REVISE GIVES NO ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
TO PAY THE WORKERS AT THE
CURRENT LEVEL. IF YOU WERE ONE
OF THE COMMENTS THAT AND I KNOW
WE'RE ALL HEARING THIS IS THAT
OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM IS IN
CRISIS AND- WE HAVE TO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIRS
QUESTIONS. AND I KNOW SOMETIMES
IT'S DIFFICULT TO ASK ANSWER
THEM YOU KNOW SIMPLY HERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
DIFFERENT FACTORS BUT I THINK AS
WE WORK TO FINALIZE THE BUDGET
IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THAT HAS
TO BE A- IN. THE AREA IS. OUR
HEAD START- THERE WAS A BUDGET
REQUEST SPECIFIC BUDGET REQUEST
FOR FIFTY MILLION. AND I WILL
TELL YOU THAT I WAS DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T INCLUDE
THIS- IT IDENTICAL THE FUNDING-
TO RAISE THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR HEAD START TEACHERS.
SALARIES FOR HEAD START
TEACHERS. ARE DEEPLY EQUITABLE
WHEN YOU COMPARE THE T. TWO K.
TWELVE- TO COMPARE TO THE TO K.
TWELVE COLLEAGUES FOR A TYPICAL
HEAD START TEACHER WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE THEY'RE MAKING
ABOUT FORTY ONE THOUSAND A YEAR.
WHERE AS- THE SALARY FOR A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER. IS SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND A YEAR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WE WE'RE WE'RE
LOSING OUR TEACHERS. AND IT IS A
PROBLEM WITH SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE- SOMEHOW NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS. SO THAT WE CAN TAKE
CARE OF AS THEY SAY OUR LITTLES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SOMEONE EVER I KNOW
THEY'RE NOT HERE BUT WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON WEBEX
CAN WE CAN WE BRING THEM UP.
VIDEO VIDEO. AND OF COURSE
THERE. WILL BE A THIRD AYE SUREWHO IT IS WITH CD BUT IT ONCE
YOU START TALKING WE CAN SEE YOU
. ON HI MR HI MISTER CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES THERE YOU ARE.
HI VIRGINIA EARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION VIRGINIA GOOD TO SEE
YOU SO MAYBE YOU COULD HELP US
SOLVE THIS RIDDLE BECAUSE BUT
THE SUMMER RACETHERE WERE
GETTING AT IS WE 100% VALUE THE
CCP YOU CONTRACTED GIVE YOU KNOW
THAT ENTITY IN THAT WORK FORCE-
DIGNITY IN. LIVING WAGES AND
BENEFITS AND SO FORTH AND BE
ABLE TO COLLECTIVELY ORGANIZED
BUT WE KEEP GOING BACK TO
SOMETIMES ADMINISTRATION AND
FINANCE DEPARTMENT SO YOU KNOW
WE CAN'T WORK ON ALL THESE OTHER
RATES BECAUSE THE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE FOCUS ON THIS PIECE
SO HOW MUCH OF THE OVERALL PIE
IS C. C. P. U. S. ALL OTHERS
THAT ARE IMPACTED. BY THE RATES
AND POTENTIAL RATE ADJUSTMENTS.
YEAH I THINK IT THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SO TO CLARIFY-
THERE ARE THREE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS ARE CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS. FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES AND LICENSE EXEMPT SO OF
THOSE THREE FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOME PROVIDERS AND LICENSE EXAM
PROVIDERS ARE THAT RECEIVE
SEVENTY SIX. ARE REPRESENTED BY.
BY THE UNION- AT THE CENTER
BASED PROGRAMS ARE NOT. BASED ON
DATA FROM OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
SO THIS IS PRE TRANSITION OF
CHILD CARE TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES- SO THIS
INCLUDES. ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
STATE PRESCHOOL CAL WORK STAGES
TWO AND THREE. FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOME NETWORKS GENERAL CHILDCARE
ARE MIGRANT PROGRAMS ND THAT
CARE FOR CHILDREN WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES PROGRAMS. OF THOSE
ALL OF THOSE PROGRAMS 55% OF
SEARCH OF CHILDREN THAT WERE
ENROLLED IN CTE PROGRAMS IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY. WERE I'M
IN CENTER BASED PROGRAMS SO OVER
HALF OF CHILDREN AND ROLLED OUT
WERE RECEIVING CARE AND A CENTER
PROGRAM. WHEREAS 31% OR IN
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES AND
ABOUT 15% WERE IN LICENSE EXEMPT
NOW THEY EXACT PERCENTAGES VARY
BY PROGRAM AND SO I WOULD DEFER
TO DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ON MORE CURRENT ESTIMATES FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS. I WILL SAY THT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. THE MAJORITY
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IS OPERATED
AND CENTERS. WELL I'M NOT SURE I
KIND OF GOT THE MATH BUT IN
PLAIN ENGLISH IT SEEMS THAT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY ARE NOT
PART OF THE C. C. P.'S CONTRACT
SO IT SEEMS THAT THE STATE
SOMETIMES STALLS AND SAYS OH
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BECAUSE WE NEED TO. FOCUS
ON THE CONTRACT AND IT JUST IT
HOLDS IT UP FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
AND SO I JUST THINK THAT'S A BIT
OF A FALSE CHOICE IN IT.
UNNECESSARILY DELAYS- ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE WHICH HE NO SIMPLE
ECONOMICS IMPACTS THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL STRUCTURE OF THE CHILD
CARE FIELD IN CALIFORNIA SO.
WE'LL HAVE A PROPOSAL ON THIS
WEEK'S COME BACK AND- NO ONE'S
HERE TO ASK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
SO WE'LL HOLD THIS ISSUE. OPEN
AND PROCEED NOW- THAT'S IT FOR
THE AGENDA IS ITEMS. AND I THINK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALREADY
ADDRESSED ISSUES- THROUGHOUT
THE- AGENDA SO FAR THIS
AFTERNOON SO WITH THAT WE WILL
CONCLUDE THE- STRUCTURED PART OF
THE AGENDA. AND GO NOW TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. SO WE'RE GONNA START
FIRST WITH PEOPLE IN THE ROOM.
AND WE CAN LINE UP OVER HERE ON
THE WALL. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS
SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS. WHEN I
TRY TO BE PASSED BY DO IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR LAST COMMENT
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
I'M BEHALF OF C. C. P. U. R.
MEMBERS REPRESENT. CARE FOR
CHILDREN THAT 1100% SUBSIDIZED
WHERE CENTERS DO HAVE ALSO
PRIVATE PAY WHICH HELPS OFFSET
THE COST BOTH ARE IN CRISIS. AND
WE ARE SHE ATE THE JHELUM THE
CONVERSATIONS THE MINISTRATIONS
HAVING BUT TO YOUR POINT WE NEED
DOLLARS MANY DOLLARS INVESTED
NOW WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCREASE RATES AND EDS- WE ARE
SEEING ONE IN TEN CHILD CARE OF
FAMILY PROVIDERS CLOSE AND THOSE
NUMBERS ARE STILL OFFSET BY THE
INVESTMENTS. SO THE NUMBERS. ARE
FOR EXISTING ONES ADDITIONALLY
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE BENEFITS WE
HAVE OUR JAIL AND SEE WE
CONTINUE TO NEGOTIATE- BUT WE
HAVE PROPOSALS ON THE TABLE TO
HAVE REAL DOLLAR AMOUNTS. THAT
WE COULD INVESTMENT IMMEDIATELY
WE WERE APPRECIABLE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE WOULD PUTTING
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE IN FOR THEM
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE
DOLLARS.
AND ON THE K. THROUGH TWELVE NO
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE- SUMMER
SCHOOL- C. S. C. S. C. A. P. THE
SUMMER BRIDGE PROPOSAL. BE
FUNDED ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT EIGHTY MILLION
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE TO BE I'M
GOING DOLLARS IT'S AN IMPORTANT
SAFETY NET FOR OUR- CLASSIFIED
WORKERS. WERE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
THE SCHOOL NUTRITION PROPOSAL-
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
QUESTIONNAIRE DOLLARS NEAR MORE
OF WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. FOR THIS
PRIORITIES GIVEN TO THE WORK
FORCE FOR RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION ESPECIALLY FOR
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE HIRED WHICH
SHORT TERM DOLLARS ROM POPE IN
NINETEEN AGREEMENT IN A. R. P.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIRST MAKE
YOUR GETS CAUGHT HI JESSICA
PSYCHO ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW- FIRST OF ALL WE WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE EASY
COALITION AND ASK FOR INCREASED
PROVIDER RATES FOR DIGNIFIED
WAGES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT LOCAL HEAD START
PROGRAMS INCREASE FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS AND
RESTORATION OF THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS RELATIVE TO
T. K. WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
THE INTERACTION OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT WITH THE SIMULTANEOUS
EXPANSION OF T. K. WILL RESULT
IN A FISCAL DISINCENTIVE FOR
DISTRICTS. CONSEQUENTLY WE URGE
CHANGES TO THE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT PROPOSAL TO ONLY
APPLY TO EIGHTY EIGHT IN K.
TWELVE AND THEN ACTUAL TKA
ATTENDANCE WOULD BE ADDED ON TOP
OF THE HOLD HARMLESS- K. TWELVE
ADA FURTHERMORE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE ASSEMBLY TO
CONSIDER HOW THEY LEVERAGE THE
EXPANSION OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TO TAKE STEPS TO
ADVANCE UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL WITH
IN THE BUDGET AND A COST NEUTRAL
WAY ALLOWING ELEAZAR TO SERVE K.
ELIGIBLE KIDS IN HEAD START OR
STATE PRESCHOOL. THANK YOU.
SHARE MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE HOLD HARMLESS-
PROVISIONS FOR THIS YEAR BUT WE
WOULD NOTE THAT WE ARE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EXCLUSION
FOR NON CLASROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS- I WOULD KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF. NON CLASSROOM BASED
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF IN PERSON STUDY- IT'S
THERE'S A LOT OF HYBRID PROGRAMS
IS NOT JUST ONLINE AND IT'S NOT
JUST- HOME SCHOOL SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE. HYBRID
PROGRAMS BEING EXCLUDED SINCE
THEY'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT AT A
LOSS DUE TO COVER NINETEEN-
WE'RE ALSO VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
NOT BEING INCLUDED IN THE THREE
YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE HOLD
HARMLESS- IN THE OUT YEARS AND
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
INCLUSION THERE AS WELL. AND
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE OVERALL-
EQUITY ON THE NEW AND EXPANDED-
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CARLOS ROW HOUSE WITH
THE KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOLS AND REPRESENTING THE
FORTY SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
COUNTING HERE TO EXPRESS HER
SUPPORT FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA GROWTH FOR THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION THE
MAY REVISE WHICH WILL ASSIST
WITH INFLATION RATE STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND RISING OPERATIONAL
COSTS AND WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AN
IMPORTANT ROLE THE COUNTY
OFFICES PLAY IN THE WORKS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE- AND
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZE AUGMENTING THAT
FUNDING SO THAT STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY UNDUPLICATED STUDENTS
AND THOSE WITH DISABILITIES-
HAVE ACCESS TO THE ESOURCE TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT
EXIST AND TO ADDRESS THE
LEARNING LOST ME TO GET THE BE
LEARNING LOSS OCCURRED DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COULD ALLY WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER WE LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GÓMEZ REYES FOR- DISCUSSING
FAMILY FEES AND HOLD HARMLESS IN
THE RATES WE'D LIKE TO- WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
WAITING FAMILY FEES FOR ONE YEAR
BUT ENCOURAGED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADAPT ADOPT A
PACKAGE THAT WE DID FOR TWO
YEARS AND COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND TO THE BEST
SERVE FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS WE
DEFINITELY ALIGNER COMMENTS WITH
THE EAT EAT TO RAISE RATES AND
PROVIDE. UPDATES FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M BRIAN RIVAS
ON BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STEM TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT I'LL
JUST SHARED THE NEED FOR THIS IS
VAST TOWARDS SERIOUS IN THE
LATEST ROUND OF ASSESSMENTS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT LATINO AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
20% OR LESS MATT FOR EXCEEDED
STANDARDS IN MATH WE THINK THE
BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THAT IS
IMPROVE TEACHER INSTRUCTION AND
YOU CAN DO THAT MOST EFFECTIVELY
THEIR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION PUT TOGETHER
PROPOSAL THAT LEVERAGES THE
DOLLARS DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS AND ALSO- PLANS TO
USE A PORTION OF THE FUNDING FOR
BUILDING UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGH A COUNTY OFFICE LED
EFFORT TO BUILD OUT THINGS LIKE
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE WHERE
TEACHERS CAN GO AND LEARN FROM
ONE ANOTHER LEARN FOM EXPERTS
AND ALSO TRAINED TEACHER IN
SCHOOL SITE LEADERS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON PC
NOTHING LESS OUT OF WITH
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER BUT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION OUR GOAL WITH THIS ASK
THIS TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
INCLUSION AND SUCCESS FOR THE
STATE'S ENGLISH LEARNERS FOR THE
FIRST ONE IS YOU WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING
THE FUNDING FOR THE EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT GRANT BUT
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
MORE FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR TO
SUPPORT ENGLISH LEARNERS TWO FOR
A TOTAL OF TWENTY MINUTES TWENTY
MILLION- EITHER GONNA STATIONS
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDE AT TEN MILLION
APPROPRIATION FOR THE BILINGUAL
TEACHER PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
GRANT. AND WE WANT TO ASK FOR A
ONE MILLION APPROPRIATION
ONGOING OF- TO APPROPRIATE AS
FOR IT IS FOR THE DISAGGREGATION
OF DATA IN ORDER TO STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S GUIDANCE AND
RESOURCES TO ENSURE. LONG TERM
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS ARE
CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED AND
PROVIDED WITH TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU WELL NOW THAT PROCEED
WITH PEOPLE CALLING IN. WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE MOVIE. AIM
FOR ANYONE WHO HAS IMPRESSED THE
ONE ZERO COMMAND YOU MAY DO SO
NOW TO ALSO INTO THE QUEUE.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN THEY'RE
ALL. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
FIFTEEN LINES IN Q. AND WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE FORTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GUARDIAN
MEMBERS JARED CALL WITH NEAREST
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON CHILD
CARE- IN SUPPORT OF THE FOOD
WITH CARE BUDGET REQUEST THAT
WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISED. WANT TO START BY TAKING
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INVESTMENT IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
TO RESTORE. A STATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEALS SERVED
IN CHILD CARE BUT THE COST OF
FOOD IS WRITTEN MORE THAN 10%
OVER THE PAST YEAR DUE TO
INFLATION AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO ARE THEMSELVES
OFTEN LIVING ON LOW INCOME ARE
STRUGGLING MORE THAN EVER TO
AFFORD THE HEALTHY MEALS FOR
KIDS IN THEIR CARE. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO BUILD ON LAST
YEAR'S INVESTMENT BY FUNDING THE
FOOD THE CARE PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD ENABLE ALL CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO QUALIFY FOR MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT EQUIVALENT TO THE
HIGHEST FEDERAL RATE FOR MEALS
SERVED IN THE FEDERAL MAIL
PROGRAM JUST LIKE THE STATE IS
NOW GOING TO DO FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE. WITH THAT ADEQUATE
FUNDING AND SUPPORT YEAH HE HAS
THE POWER TO FILL THE GAP IN THE
GLOBAL ACT THAT THE HEALTHY MEAL
WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF THE CHILD
CARE WORKFORCE WE JUST ALSO WANT
TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE ECB
COALITION ASKS. THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FIFTY ONE. THEIR STRUGGLE WITH
CHRIS STRATEGY I'LL BE MAKING TO
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF CREATE
CALIFORNIA WE- URGED THE
ASSEMBLY TO CONSIDER A ONE
BILLION INVESTMENT COULD SUPPORT
STANDARDS ALIGNED CURRICULUM
MATERIALS IN ARTS EDUCATION WELL
PAYING WAGES ND HIGH QUALITY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEACHERS TO HELP IMPLEMENT THE
NEW STANDARDS FOR THE SUBJECT
AREA. THE POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR
THAT BUDGET ATKINS REFLECTED IN
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SECONDLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WITH SUPPORT A FAMILY MEMBER ALL
DONALD COMMENTS TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES WE
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL ONE
TWENTY BILLION GENERAL FUND
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR MARY BY
TO SUPPORT NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
MODERNIZATION GO THAT SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE ARE
WE ARE REQUESTING A FULL
FACILITIES FUNDING TO BE
INCREASED FURTHER CONSISTENT
WITH THE TEN BILLION INCLUDED.
IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET BLUEPRINT
THANK YOU. A BLIND. FORTY SIX
FOUR SIX. HI THIS IS ROBERT
MANDARIN FROM CHILDREN NOW I
WANTED TO COMMENT FIRST ON THE
DISCRETIONARY BLOCK GRANTS-
WE'RE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
PROVIDING ONE TIME MONIES WITH
THIS DISCUSSION BUT WOULD LIKE
TO SUGGEST CHANGING THE FORMULA
TO A MORE EQUITY FOCUSED ONE
SPECIFICALLY USING THE LC F.
AFTER SHOULD BE SHOULD MECHANISM
TO DISTRIBUTE ANY DISCRETIONARY
DOLLARS. ARE ALSO USED IN LTE IF
APPLES IN TERMS OF- THE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND USING A
PORTION OF IT TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOSTER YOUTH AND
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF
THE COMPANY THOSE- SECOND WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
REBALANCING OF ONE TIME AND
ONGOING FUNDS TO FREE UP MONIES
FOR EXPANDING THE ULTRA FAST
FUNDING SYSTEM. AND WOULD
SUGGEST TRYING TO BALANCE
BTWEEN BUILDING THE BASE AND
ULTRA FAST AND AUGMENTING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS AND FINELY- HI TO MAKE
DOLLARS ACTUALLY THE KIDS THAT
ARE GENERATING THE FUNDS WE
WOULD SUGGEST- FINING THE
COMPLETION OF THE L. CAP PORTAL
THIS IS A TOOL THAT WOULD HELP
TAKE BLACK INFORMATION FROM OUT
CAPS IN A SYSTEMATIC WAY TO KNOW
WHAT WE'RE BUYING WITH FOR
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION.
GRANTS THANKS SO MUCH. YOU PINE
FORTY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MCCARTY IN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GETTING COLDER AND REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION IN
REGARDS TO THE MAY REVISE
ALTHOUGH WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE
FUNDING FOR ONE YEAR EXTENSION
OF THE SINGLE USE VOUCHER
REIMBURSEMENT OF CARE BASED ON
ENROLLMENT NOT ATTENDANCE AND
AWAITING A FAMILY FEAST WE TOO
ARE CONCERNED THAT WITH FOR ONE
YEAR PRIOR TO THE MAY REVISE WE
WERE GETTING PREPARED- WE WERE
HEARING THERE WERE JUST A MOMENT
HAPPENING FOR TENS OF. RIGHT WE
CAN WE'D LIKE THEM TO GO THROUGH
THAT AGAIN. WE ALSO ARE
CONCERNED ALTHOUGH A CHILD CARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IMPLEMENTED
LAST JANUARY FIRST. NEARLY 50%
OF HIGH QUALITY CENTERS AND MANY
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME PROVIDERS
DID NOT SEE ANY INCREASE AT ALL.
FINALLY WE WERE PLEASED TO SEE
TWENTY MILLION IN SUPPORT
CAPACITY BUILDING THE COMMUNITY
BASED EIGHT PIECE ENROLLING NEW
SPOT. FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS IS
BASED ON THE FUNDING AND
PROVIDER PAYMENTS THEREIN LIES
THE PROBLEM. THE PROVIDER RATE
HELLO AN UNSUSTAINABLE AVERAGING
BETWEEN FIVE FIFTY AND TEN PER
OUR- COMMUNITY AGENCIES GET THE
REIMBURSEMENT BASED ON THOSE
RATE. DURING BECAUSE OF IT UP TO
NOW THERE WERE DOZENS OF
UNFUNDED MANDATE. SHIFTING TO
REMOTE WORKING OR AGENCIES DID
NOT RECEIVE ANY FUNDING DURING
THE PANDEMIC. CURRENTLY
CASELOADS ARE RUNNING ABOUT ONE
TWO HUNDRED THREE. FAMILY PRIOR
TO CO THAT IT WAS ONE TO FORTY.
FINALLY WE LIKE ONLINE ARE IN
BUT WITH THAT OF THE EASY
COALITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND. GREAT STAFF WORK FOR ERIN.
NEXT BAKER PLEASE MEG. WE HAVE
LINE FIFTY FOUR. CAPPING YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SHALL DENTAL
BE AWFUL THE YOU DID THAT YOU
THE BEER I'M CALLING TODAY TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE ITEM
PERTAINING TO CHILD CARE ON
BEACHES ONE EIGHTY TWO ASSEMBLY
FEEL WAY BURKE ONE EIGHTY THREE
HOLD HARMLESS POLITICS ONE
NINETEEN THE CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM THE TWO TO TWENTY
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
CAPACITY GRANT. AND THE CHILD
CARE BLOCK PROVISION PROVIDED BY
DIMMING REVIEW CAN WE ARE
REQUESTING FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
NOW WHAT I'M GOING AND A HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME TO FULLY FUND
HEALTHCARE AND THE RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AS WELL TIME OFF YOUR
SUPPORT FIFTY TWO YEAR JOINT
LATE FOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION THE BENEFITS ARE
CRITICAL TO IMPROVE THE BILITY
FOR THEIR CHILD CARE WORK FOR.
WE APPRECIATE THE HEARING TODAY
AND A LOOK FORWARD. TO CONTINUED
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. PINE SIXTY TWO. HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PTA
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL AROUND
INCREASING THE BASE I THINK
WITHOUT THE A FAST AND WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
LPS THAT EACH EACH TRONG WITH
THE COURT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
AND MAY PROPOSAL HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MANAGE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND ENSURES WELL
THEY'RE NOT PENALIZED FOR
COLBERT RELATE RELATED ABSENCES.
AND FINALLY CPA'S OPPOSED THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION PROPOSAL
TO ALLOW FOR G. K. LOCAL PAYMENT
OPTIONS THANK YOU. YOU. NINE
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT OF THE NONPROFIT
COALITION PRODUCTS GO HOUSING WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION TO THE S. AND P. AND TO
EXPEDITE FUNDING INTO THE
CURRENT YEAR ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE ASSEMBLY IT'S A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL AND WE
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO PUSH
FOR THE STATE TO CONTINUE ITS
ROLE IN FUNDING THE BUILDING AND
MODERNIZATION OF SCHOOL BUT THE
BACKLOG OF APPLICATIONS TO
PRODUCE THREE. BILLION AND-
EIGHT OF ONE POINT FIVE PER. AND
AFTER A FEW. THE MAY REVISION TO
PROPOSE FOR BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS. SIMPLY CONTINUE THE
PRACTICE OF METERING FACILITIES
RESOURCES IN A WAY THAT IS MOST
SACRAMENTO TO THOSE IN ALREADY
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WE SUPPORT THE
TEN BILLION IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL FOR SCHOOL FACILITIES.
AND THAT INCLUDES TWO BILLION IN
FUNDING DEDICATED. TO SEE
CAPABILITIES WHICH WILL
OTHERWISE NOT BE MET IN THE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM UNDER
EXISTING REGULATIONS. LASTLY WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. THE
FUNDING OF MEDICAL FOR PATAKI
PREVIOUS STATE AND LOCAL TAX
PAYER INVESTMENTS IN SCHOOL
FACILITIES THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIN ASKING THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP FOR THE FUTURE
BERNIE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AND
THAT OTHER ONE AND A HALF
BILLION FOR THAT EVERY ELIGIBLE
HIGH NEED GONE THE STATE CAN
BECOME A RACIALLY TRUST
RELATIONSHIP CENTER COMMUNITY
SCHOOL WOULD LIKE TO THINK PDP
AND SDP FOR LISTENING TO YOU
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS AND THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL GRAND DESIGN
AND IMPLEMENTATION WITHOUT MANY
OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON SHARED
DECISION MAKING AND INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
REFLECTED IN THE FRAMEWORK ARE
SAFE AND PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING ANNUAL REPORTING A
PUBLIC PRESENTATION OF PLANTS
THE CLERKS. THANK THE GOVERNMENT
DR RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE EQUITY TENANTS BASED
INCLUDING GRANT PROVISIONS IN
TRAILER BILL WE APPLAUD
RESTRICTING GRANTEES FROM USING
COMMUNITIES GOLF FANS I'M
PUNITIVE DISCIPLINARY PRACTICES
LIKE SCHOOL POLICE AND REBIRTH
OFFICER TO HARM STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
CREATE RACIALLY JUST UNDER START
OF SCHOOL CLIMATE YOU MUST FROM
CRIMINALIZATION TO CONNECTION
AND IMPLEMENT TRANSFORMATIVE
JUSTICE PRACTICES AND CULTURALLY
ROOTED PROGRAM. AND LASTLY WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION KEEP
YOUR WORK FIRST PROPOSAL NOW IS
THE TIME TO BOTH THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
EXPAND THE COUNSELOR. OF COURSE
THANK YOU. HE WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SEVEN. SEVEN OH.
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS TOMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND I JUST LIKE TO
ELEVATE OUR PROPOSAL FOR FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING WHICH WOULD FUND THE
CREATION OF TWO CRITICAL FULL
TIME STOCK POSITIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO FOCUS
ON LGBTQ PASCUA EQUITY WE'RE
DANCING THE PROPOSAL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALLOW ON BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ
CAUCUS. ON BECAUSE WE HAVE- THE
INTERVENTION LAW. REQUIREMENTS
FOR ALL PLUS BUT OF COURSE HE'S
LIES NEED TO BE PROPERLY IN
ORDER TO REALIZE THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN A CRITICAL PARTNER IN THIS
WORK BUT IT DOES NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE AN ONGOING STAFF POSITION
THAT AND DEDICATED FULL TIME TO
CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST LEGAL
FRAMEWORK RELATING TO LGBTQ PLUS
STUDENT SO THIS FUNDING WILL
ENSURE THAT THE CRITICAL NEED IS
NOT THERE AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS ELEAZAR CO
EASE AND THE COMMUNITY HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE CENTRALIZED AND
ACTIVE SUPPORT THAT THEY REALLY
NEED IN ORDER TO MONITOR AND
MEET LEGAL REQUIREMENTS SH. OF
THE CENTRALIZED WITHIN THEIR
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT NOW AND
AS LGBT KEEP CLASS AND
PARTICULARLY TRANSGENDER YOUTH
AND STUDENTS ARE UNDER ATTACK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE INCLUSION OF
THE ON GOING FUNDING TO ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO MAINTAIN AND
IT'S INTENTIONAL WORK IN
IMPROVING. OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS THANKS SO
MUCH. OUR NEXT COMMENT WAS FROM
BLIND FORTY ONE. SHARE MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS. AT LEAST I CAN YOU
GUYS HEAR ME. YEAH OKAY- MY NAME
ISN'T THAT. MY NAME IS NOT THAT
STRAIGHTFORWARD KIDDING GO AND
WE ARE GAVE GRATEFUL FOR THE
GOVERNOR SAID THAT HIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT APPROPRIATE TIME
INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE AND
PRESCHOOL. AND AS MEMBERS OF THE
EIGHTEEN BUDGET COALITION WE
ADVOCATE TO PROMOTE EQUITY BY
SERVING THE HIGHEST NEED
CHILDREN. WHAT YOU SUPPORT THE
INCREASE WAGES FOR PROVIDERS.
THE WAY BEING A FAMILY FEES AND
INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS. ARE WE DO
KNOW THAT THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EARLY LEARNING SIX TO MAKE OUR
EASY SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE. AND
INCLUSIVE BUT TO DO THAT
CALIFORNIA MUST PROHIBIT
SUSPENSION MISFORTUNES AND CHILD
CARE SETTING. AND ALSO PROVIDE
THAT YOU SEE WORKFORCE WITH
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS THE WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS. AND ONE OF THE THREE
BILLS RESOURCE THAT IS EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION. WHICH DESPERATELY
NEEDS AN INCREASE TO ITS
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR FROM 5% TO TEN
PERCENT. IN ORDER TO CREATING
QUOTES HAVE BEEN BARMAN INSTEAD
OF EXCLUDING ARE EXPELLING
CHILDREN- IF JULIE TOLD. OTHER
INDOOR LANGUAGE LEARNERS. ALSO
THE GOVERNOR IS DEFINITELY ON
THE RIGHT TRACK INCREASING
DIGESTIVE FACTOR FOR CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES. AND WE WILL
WANT TO EXPAND AND STRENGTHEN
INCLUSION POLICIES AND PRACTICES
IN THE PRESCHOOL TO EQUITABLY
SUPPORT BY DIVERSE NEEDS OF ALL
CHILDREN. SO WE'VE SUBMITTED-
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
DEVELOPED FROM AN INCLUSION
WORKGROUP. ADDITIONAL FEES FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO PASS A
BUDGET THAT PROVIDE. THAT FOR
THEM HIGH QUALITY. HEALTH
SERVICES THAT MEET THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF ALL CHILDREN.
PARTICULARLY OUR BABY AND MOSTLY
INSURANCE TEACHERS HAVE MORE
SUPPORT AND HIGHER WAGES THE
PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK WE HAVE LONG
NUMBER FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CONDE TANG WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE AND THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR THE
FUTURE LEARNING ONE THANK OUR
STATE LEADERS AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO EXPAND THE
COMMUNICATION INITIATIVE. THE
PREVENTION OF BUILDING UP HER
PREVIOUS CAMPAIGN THAT
GRASSROOTS COMMUNITIES HELP WHEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN COULD THOUGH THE
FACT THAT COMMUNICATION MODELS
IMPACTED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND DISTRICT. THE OTHER CRITICAL
THAT THAT EXPANSION HIGHS NOT
ONLY BECAUSE STATE LEVEL BUT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL AND WE
RECOMMEND AT LEAST A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THE INITIATIVE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FAMILIES
AND WILL LIKE THIS LANGUAGE
AROUND HOW THIS INVESTMENT WILL
ALSO BE USED TO BUILD CAPACITY.
PROBABLY EIGHTEEN TV BOTH OF THE
ONE OF THE PORT THE ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
ALONG WITH THE PROPOSED
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND SHARED
DECISION MAKING EVERY NOT FOR
NEW FROM NINETEEN BOTH BETWEEN
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE. THANK YOU
. WE HAVE LONG NUMBERS. ONE
AFTER TURN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KEITH- WHO WILL GIVE IT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA OF FOOD BANKS WE
APPRECIATE THE FOR ALL THE
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROVISIONS THAT
ARE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND MAY REVISED PROVISION
TO BE FULLY FUNDED INCLUDING
REALLOCATING UNSPENT FUNDS FROM
AUGMENTED BEING BIRTH MINT READY
TWENTY WITH THE RIVERS EXPIRE
FOR KITCHEN INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH INTRUSION APARTMENTS ARE
IN HIGH NEED OF WE ARE ALSO
REQUESTING THE FOLLOWING TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION MULTIPLE YOUR
FUNDING FOR EVALUATION OF
PRESCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO
EAT ALLOWED SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
ONLY ONE FULL MEAL ON A HALF DAY
THAT ALL CHILDREN ARE DISCHARGED
FROM SCHOOL THE ONLY IF YOU
ESTATE NOT APPROVED A WAIVER FOR
PROVIDING NON CONGREGATE MEALS
SUCH AS GRABBING GO TO. INCREASE
SECURITY AND PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
FOR SCHOOL INCOME DATA
COLLECTION IN ADDITION TO THESE
INVESTMENTS WHEN CHILDREN ARE IN
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE THE
FOLLOWING THAT'S MEANT TO
FURTHER ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
HAVE ACCESS TO NUTRITION ANY
CALL YOUR LONG ESTABLISHED
BETTER OUT OF SCHOOL TIME BLUES
ME CHRISTIAN PROGRAM TO PREVENT
CHILD HUNGER DURING SCHOOL
BREAKS OR CAMPUS CLOSURES. THE
POOR INVESTMENT MAKING EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY THE THIRD CHILDREN
DURING SUMMER MONTHS WHEN SCHOOL
CAMPUSES ARE CLOSE AND FINALLY
WE NEED TO INVEST NOT. AND I.
YOUR BY PROVIDING FREE MEALS
ALSO CHAO CARE BY ENABLING ALL
TELL CARE TO CALL FOR THE LEVEL
REIMBURSE FOR THE THEY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMENT ON LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON AN BUDGET
LEADER MAKES WERE SENT OR STATE
BUDGET AND TELL HUNGER. NEXT WE
HAVE LONG LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS- THIS IS SERRA WILLIS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR TEACH
PLUS CALIFORNIA BERKELEY'S
DEFEATED OPTIONAL PLANS BECAUSE
OF BOTH ADMINISTRATION AND IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS BEING
INVESTED NOT FORGET FAST AND YET
LIKE OUR COLLEAGUE THE CHILDREN
NOW WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT WE
WON'T KNOW IF YOU CENTER
ACTUALLY ADVANCING EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AT THE TEN DAY. IF WE
DON'T HAVE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS ARE BEING
USED TO THAT AND WE RECOMMEND OF
THE BUDGET INCLUDING INVESTMENT
OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
DESIGNING COMPLETE THE DATA
PORTAL NOT TO COLLECT
INFORMATION FROM ALL THE ALL
CAPS TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY.
AND ALSO AS A LEAD TO THE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS DISCRETIONARY
BLOCK GRANT- WE ALSO TO ENSURE
THAT THAT IS INVESTED
EFFECTIVELY RECOMMENDED TO BE
DISTRIBUTED A MORE EQUITABLE
FORMULA WE ALSO RECOMMEND
INCLUDE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
INCORPORATING IN COORDINATED
PLANNING- PERHAPS WITH A
SUPPLEMENT TO HELP CAP. A WE ARE
BORDER- AT OTHER. YOU JUST
MENTIONED OF. IN THAT AND
COMMUNING. INITIATIVE AND
UNLOCKED OUR A COUPLE. TO ENSURE
THAT BUILD THE CAPACITY OF LOCAL
LEADERS THIS IMPORTANT WORK. AND
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
ONGOING FOCUS ON ENSURING
SUSTAINABLE THE PERSONAL SUPPORT
EDUCATED WORK FORCE. TO THAT AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT THAT
THE PROPOSAL FOR THE RESIDENCY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER AND
HOPE WE CAN HELP ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF. ENSURING THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE MANY OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM- THE URGE TO STATE
EXPLORE HOW TO BETTER SUPPORT
AND BUILD CAPACITY OF LOCAL
LEADERS TO NOT ONLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE STATE PROGRAMS
BUT DEVELOP. COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THEIR
STAFFING NEEDS INCLUDING
ENSURING A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER SIXTY SIX.
HELLO CAN MEMBERS MARYLAND
ACCUSING REPRESENTING AT LEAST
BEST AFTER SCHOOL ENRICHMENT
PROGRAM SERVING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS IN LOS ANGELES
CALLING REGARDING EXPANDED
LEARNING WHILE WE'RE THRILLED
ABOUT THE STATE INVESTMENT IN
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS MORE
ACTION MUST BE TAKEN TO ENSURE
THESE PROGRAMS ARE SUCCESSFUL.
RESPECTFULLY WE URGE YOU TO
EXTEND THE HOLD HARMLESS AND
PANDEMIC FLEXIBILITY ON
ATTENDANCE FOR A SECOND TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PROGRAM THROUGH
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO CALENDAR
YEAR OUR ATTENDANCE HAS ALSO
FLUCTUATED DRAMATICALLY AS A
RESULT OF COMING NINETEEN WE CAN
SEARCHES AND WITHOUT ACTION
PROGRAMS LIKE OURS COULD LOSE
FUNDING IN FUTURE YEARS WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT STAFF
AND STUDENTS BY PROVIDING AFTER
SCHOOL- AND WRITING ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY PROGRAMS OF
THE PROPORTIONAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS. TO ACCOMMODATE FOR
RISING COSTS WE ALSO ASK THAT
YOU FIND A STATE WIDE WORK GROUP
TO FOCUS ON EUROPEAN
FERMENTATION AND SUSTAINABILITY
PLANNING AS LATE AB TWENTY FIVE
OH ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARDIO
AND LASTLY WE ASK YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
YOUTH WHO WERE LEFT OUT OF THE
EXTENSION WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION ON THE FIRST
PROPOSAL. AND APPRECIATE
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT. IS FROM LINE EIGHTY FOUR.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF PERSONALIZED
LEARNING SCHOOLS AND SERVICES
ALSO KNOWN AS A PLUS WE HAVE
EIGHTY FIVE MEMBER SCHOOLS AND
OVER SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT THE USE VARIANCE EDUCATION
MODELS TO NON CLASSROOM BASED
SECTOR MANY OF THEM HAVING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CLASSROOMS. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE- THE MADE
REVISED PROPOSAL THAT INCREASES
THE HIGHER UP FUNDING FOR PROP
NINETY EIGHT THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. IT'S AN ALL
SCHOOLS HOWEVER WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH ONE
PROVISIONS IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. THAT PICKS
WINNERS AND LOSERS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ISSUE OF HOLD HARMLESS
FUNDING. OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL%
YEAR. I'M MANY NON CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOLS ALSO EXPERIENCED
DECLINE ENROLLMENT. THIS IS THE
ISSUE AND WE THINK THAT ALL
STUDENTS SHOULD BE TREATED THE
SAME WITH RESPECT TO THAT
FUNDING. UNFORTUNATELY THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE A SHORT
CHANGES THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
. THOUSAND NOW CLASSROOM BASED
TUNES THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND
ESSENTIALLY IT IT SHORT CHANGING
THEM BY PICKING. BILLS WERE IN
THE CLASSROOM OR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT IN THE CLASSROOM AND WE
THINK THAT BOTH LEARNING MODEL
SHOULD BE FUNDED EQUALLY SO FOR
THAT REASON WE ACCEPT THE NON
CLASSROOMBASED. ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS ALSO GET FOUR TIMES
LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT IS
FROM LINE SEVEN EIGHT. OKAY
BLAME SEVENTY WE'VE GOT THAT
HELLO MY NAME IS BRENDA POTEET
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SIERRA
CASCADE FAMILY OPPORTUNITIES WE
PROVIDE CHILD DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS IN THE FAR NORTH
EASTERN CORNER OF THE STATE
LASSEN MODOCKLAMATH COUNTY. AND
I'M CALLING TO URGETHE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT HEAD START
TEACHERS AND SALARIES AS WELL AS
THE FULL REQUEST FOR THE EASY
BUDGET COALITION WITH INFLATION
AT 8% AND THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASING EVEN FASTER THAN
EXPECTED PROGRAMS CAN'T WAIT FOR
AN- FUNDS. CAN YOU TO RISE.
WITHOUT ANY FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROGRAMS WILL BE FORCED TO CLOSE
CLASSROOMS LEAVING FAMILIES WITH
NO ACCESS TO CHILDCARE OR THE
OTHER VALUABLE SERVICES HEAD
START PROVIDES. CURRENTLY
THERE'S OVER A BILLION FEDERAL
HEAD START DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
TO SERVE. CALIFORNIA'S MOST AT
RISK CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. OF
THAT- ABOUT BILLION DOLLARS- OF
THOSE PROGRAMS 21% OF THOSE.
ENROLLMENT SLOTS ARE VACANT
CURRENTLY BECAUSE DUE TO THE
LACK OF QUALIFIED TEACHERS- BACK
21% REPRESENTS TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THAT ARE AT RISK OF BEING LOST
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE'RE ASKING
THAT THE COMMITTEE RECOGNIZE
HEAD START AS A VITAL PART OF
THE MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM. AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. SO THAT
WE CAN. HIGHER IN KEEP QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AND FOR THAT I PROGRAMS
CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
AND THE TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FIRST WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT OF BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE OF PFF
BASED FUNDING. SECOND WE WOULD
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
ALLOW ELEAZAR TO BE FUNDED IN
THE CURRENT YEAR BASED ON THEIR
PRE COVERED ABSENCE RATES. WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE BLOCK GRANT
APPROACH THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
MAY REVISED BUT WE WOULD URGE
THE ADOPTION OF A PER PUPIL
DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE DOLLARS.
AND THEN I WOULD ALSO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS FROM MR ROWE HAAS FROM
KERN COUNTY. IN SUPPORT OF THE
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL. TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. AND THEN LASTLY WE
WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION OF
PROVIDING FUNDING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF DONALD ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE. A TO
BEGIN ADDRESSING HISTORIC
INEQUITIES IN OUR STATE. A FUND.
FOR HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OUR NEXT COMMENT IS FROM
LONG IN SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR- JIM
ACCORDION MEMBERS DO IS GATHER
PUBLIC ADVOCATES FOR OUR
PARTNERS IN THE LCS OF EQUITY
COALITION WE THANK THE MINISTER
FOR HEARING US IN CAPTURING THE
SPIRIT OF OUR BUDGET REQUEST IN
THE NAY REVISED. TO EXPAND THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE
WHCH WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THROUGH YOUR
LEADERSHIP WE AND OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN ENGAGED WITH
THE INITIATIVE AS PART OF AN
ADVISORY COUNCIL IN THEATERS
CRITICAL FOR GREATER STATEWIDE
REACH BUT IT NEEDS TO GO FURTHER
TO ADDRESS THAT GAP IN LOCAL
CAPACITY. OF DISTRICTS BY
LEVERAGING THE EXPERTISE OF
COMMUNITY BASED. ORGANIZATIONS
MODEL TO PRACTICES OR GAUGING.
WE APPRECIATE THE HUNDRED XP
FOR. I WORK BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
INCREASE TWO HUNDRED NOW. TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR LOCAL
DISTRICTS WORK IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE GOOD GOAL OF THIS EXPANSION.
EXPANDING INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT WILL BE CRITICAL TO
IMPLEMENTING COMMUNITY SCHOOL
AND THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMUNISM LINE
SEVENTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON- IS
NOT WHOLLY.
READING FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
WITHOUT ACCESS NEEDED SERVICES
THIS IS A MAJOR LACK FOR MANY OF
OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITY YES OF
THE COMMITTEE RECOGNIZE HEAD
START IS A VITAL PART OF THE
NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT THAT OUR PROGRAM
CAN CONTINUE TO CARE
CALIFORNIA'S NOT VULNERABLE
FAMILY. OUR NEXT COMMUNIST
REMIND FORTY THREE. HELLO THIS
IS MARIA ROMO ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD CARE RESEARCH CENTER THE
LARGEST CHILD CARE AND FAMILY
SERVICES NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING AMBER VIDEO COUNTY
AND NORTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY-
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MCCARTY AND REYES FOR POINTING
OUT THE INADEQUACIES OF RATES
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND FOR
SUPPORTING THE ASSEMBLY A PUSH
FOR RATE INCREASES ARE CURRENTLY
ARE NOT ADEQUATE AND THEY ARE
NOT NOUGH. THERE IS A CONSTANT
STRUGGLE IN THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE TO PAY THEIR EDUCATED
WORKERS THE FAIR WAGES THEY
DESERVE MAY HAVE MAPS CLOSER AND
THEY CANNOT RETAIN THEIR STOCKS
AND MOREOVER THEY CAN'T HIRE NEW
STAFF WERE ASKING FOR INCREASES
TO OUR ENTIRE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN WORKING
DURING THIS MASS EXODUS AND
SHORTAGE. OF WORKERS THANK YOU.
NEXT TO HAVE LINE. EIGHTY HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
YVONNE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF
AND PORTANTINO SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO AND ORANGE COUNTY OPTED
EDUCATION REPORT THE NAY READ
REVISIONS ALFIE UP INVESTMENT
BURKE OKAY. A RECORD OF THAT
DEBATE PRIORITIZE DIFFERENT THE
FIFTH SENATE THAT I THINK THAT
THE BEST INTO A BUT YOU MAKE
APPS- THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMON
IS LINE EIGHTY. AFTERNOON THIS
IS JAMIE MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES FOR
RECOGNIZING THE CRISIS WITH
EIGHT EXPECTING AFTER A LATE
CHARGE CHILD EARLY CHILD CARE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MADE COMMENTS REGARDING
HEAD START. THE HA URGES THE
COMMITTEE TO FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE BUDGET TOOK
PART ACTUALLY OUR. FORMER CLUB.
BUDGET BUT AT 8% THE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASING EVEN FASTER THE
NEXT. PROGRAMS WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL IF CONSTANT TO RISE
WITH ANY SUPPORT PROGRAMS WILL
BE FORCED TO CLOSE CLASSROOMS
MEETING FAMILIES BUT NOW ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE OR THE OTHER
VALUABLE SERVICES HEAD START
PROVIDE EDUCATION SOCIAL DEPART
POLITICIAN AND PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
. YEAH COMMITTEE BACK HAD START
AS A VITAL OF THE NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
THAT ARE PART OF THAT OUR
PROGRAMS CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS. OBERNOLTE FAMILY
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BIRTH MY NAME IS PLENTY
TORRENT TORY REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AT THE
THOUGHT THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
OUR THE NAY REVISION OF LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
INVESTMENT FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHICH WILL HELP
ADDRESS INFLATION STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND RISING OPERATIONAL
COSTS. PURSUANT TO THE COUNTY
OFFICE BUDGET PRIORITY BUT YOUR
REQUEST WE ALSO REQUEST THE
LEGISLATOR PRIORITIZE INVESTED
IN DIFFERENTIATE ASSISTANCE TO
ENABLE COUNTY OFFICES CAN
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT DISTRICTS
AND CHARTERS NEED TO ADDRESSING
CLOSE PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT AND
OPPORTUNITY GAPS THAT ARE FACING
OUR KIDS AND I HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THANK. HELLO. EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ELMER MARTINEZ I REPRESENT WRONG
AMERICA AND BRADY NATION A
NETWORK OF BUSINESS LEADERS AND
SUPPORT OF ALL TO THAT AFFLICT
OUR STUDENTS AND ECONOMY. WELL
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN A
REVISED SUCH AS THE EXTENSION OF
THE FAMILY B. WAIVERS AND HOLD
HARMLESS POLICIES TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE I'M HERE TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE U. K. YOU
COALITION BUDGET PRIORITIES AND
THAT YOU CONSIDER. ADOPTING THE
MAY REVISE A LITTLE OLD CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS HARDWOODS IN THE
YEAR ADOPTING SENATE'S PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION PROPOSAL A ONE BILLION
RATE INCREASE TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS INCLUDING FIFTY
MILLION POOR HEAD START
PROVIDERS AT OUTLINED IN SENATE
BUDGET. FINALLY WE'RE HOPING
THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER RESTORING
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANTS
AT TWO HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
AS WELL AS FUNDING HEALTHCARE
AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS FOR OUR
FAMILY. YEAH I CANNOT FUTURE
THAT WORKS FOR ALL CAL WE URGE
YOU CONSIDER THESE COUPLE OPEN
THE CRITICAL IN OUR ST IN THE
FINAL BY THANK YOU CAN AGREE TO
. OUR NEXT ALLY. EIGHTEEN THE
NINE ARE YOU ON MUTE. HI THERE
AT THE MATTHEWS CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION ARE QUITE
YET ASK INCLUDES RAISING
PROVIDER RATE WAITING FAMILY
FEES AND INVESTING IN CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT. THANK TO.
CARDI MAJORITY LEADER REP S. FOR
YOUR WORK ON INCREASING CHILD
CARE PROVIDER RATE AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE POINT THAT
MAJORITY LEADER READ MENTION
WHICH IS NOT PROVIDER RATES ARE
BASED ON A FOUR YEAR OLD SURVEY
WHICH WAS TAKEN BEFORE THE
MINIMUM WAGE WINTER. THE
UNDERLYING DATA ABOUT THE SURVEY
RELIES ON EXTREMELY OUTDATED.
IRRELEVANT TO CHAIRMAN CARTY
RIGHT. WHAT WE SUPPORT OUR
PARTNERS THAT HE C. P. U. THE
MAJORITY OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN OUR CHILD CARE
PERSPECTIVES. I'M NOT MEMBERS AT
THE PPO AND ARE NOT COVERED BY
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY SENATE
AND LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
TO BASED CHILDCARE RATE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS TIME I'LL TURN THE
CONFERENCE BACK OVER TO YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
THE PUBLIC- COMMON WITH THAT WE
WILL TURN.